[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinkerview nous
sommes en direct est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinctement Adèle
bonjour je m'appelle Adèle Planchard je
viens du Massif Central j'ai rejoint les
soulèvements de la Terre depuis une
lutte contre l'artificialisation de plus
de 200 hectares agricoles en moyenne
montagne
[Musique]
voilà en Haute-Loire et je suis de
métiers boulangère et je travaille aussi
sur des chantiers forestiers en tant que
bûcheron
Christophe Christophe Bonneuil je suis
historien des sciences historien de
l'environnement
j'ai pas mal travaillé sur comment on en
est arrivé au dérèglement planétaire
actuel sur les alertes les contestations
qui ont pu avoir lieu sur des enjeux
socio-écologiques depuis pas mal de
décennies et pourquoi finalement ces
alertes et ses contestations n'ont pas
abouti à une bifurcation
et aussi sur les stratégies de la part
des élites économiques et politiques
justement pour éviter de bifurquer donc
ça c'est mes recherches sinon je suis
éditeur de la collection anthropocène
aux éditions du Seuil et le dernier bébé
c'est justement un livre avec les
soulèvements de la terre donc elle sous
les soulèvements de la terre dissous
Marcel a participé et puis comme ça
l'être humain concerné par ce qui se
passe sur terre je considère comme
faisant partie des soulèvements de la
terre j'ai participé à quelques actions
et je fais partie avec des gens comme
Philippe Descola bâtisse Morizot
Isabelle steengers d'un télo
d'universitaire d'autrices qui ont
soutenu et participé au mouvement
Marcel
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation
là ravi de pouvoir parler un petit peu
de dessoulement de la terre
du coup moi je suis doctorante en
mathématiques je me suis notamment
intéressée pas mal aux notions de
protection de la vie privée mais ce qui
m'amène aujourd'hui c'est donc mon
implication on est soulèvement de la
terre administrativement disso et voilà
moi je connais le soulèvement de la
Terre depuis à peu près un an et je me
suis pas mal impliquée dans une
commission d'enquête autour de
l'agriculture numérique j'ai notamment
écrit du coup un petit texte à ce propos
dans le livre on me dit souvent un
soulèvement et je suis également je fais
également partie du comité local 11 12
20 de Paris qui fait partie de voilà du
comité
Île-de-France de soulèvement de la terre
merci d'être venu tous les trois
aujourd'hui
on va parler forcément écologie on va
parler renseignements on va parler
dissolution on va parler violence on va
parler éco-féminisme on va parler de
tout un tas de choses on va commencer
par faire une expérience de pensée à 3
ou 4 je vais vous demander un par un
décide de me décrire les angoisses de
l'État face à vous
qui s'y colle en premier ou en première
et qu'il faut se préparer
à faire face à ces désordres et j'aurais
tendance à penser que le gouvernement
Macron est un des agents de ce
capitalisme financier mondial et qu'il
se sentent
celles des soulèvements de la terre
Macron agent entre guillemets c'est ça
un des agents la source c'est quoi
est-ce que il y a une source qui relie
Macron a ou
on a quelqu'un qui a fait partie de
l'appareil d'État mais qui est passé par
la banque Rothschild
a participé activement à des politiques
disons de
néolibéral en matière de transport les
karmacrons des choses comme ça Hubert
donc il a un certain historique de
politiques
favorable au milieu des entreprises ils
défend la start-up nation c'est quoi ces
angoisses à Emmanuel Macron face à vous
mis à part l'étude très scolaire que
vous venez me citer
en tout cas ce que j'ai pu observer
autour de moi à travers les différentes
personnes que j'ai vues à la fois venir
dans les comités locaux des soulèvement
de la terre ou participer aux
manifestations des soulèvements de la
terre c'est vraiment en fait une sorte
de prise de conscience de décalage de
d'une pluralité de différentes personnes
qui qui dont les corps se mettent en
mouvement et qui sont plus en fait dans
l'attente de prise de décision j'ai
l'impression que voilà qui a eu toute
une histoire de l'écologie notamment
écologiste où les gens en fait sont dans
l'attente de prise de décision des
décideurs parce que on pense que c'est
que à cette échelle là qui peut y avoir
des prises de décision qui qui ont
vraiment qui font en force quoi et la
question
l'expérience de pensée de Me verbaliser
les angoisses de l'appareil d'État et
d'Emmanuel Macron
et
assez rapidement je pense que c'est
vraiment le fait qu'il y a une prise de
cons enfin pas prise de conscience mais
en tout cas que les corps des gens se
mettent en mouvement et que les gens
participent activement et sortent en
fait un petit peu de leur isolement
social qui qui participent activement au
lutte qui a autour de chez eux et en
fait la peur de ne plus pouvoir faire un
projet je sais pas autoroutier un projet
d'Oméga bassine un projet quelconque
inutile autour de chez soi sans que en
fait les gens s'y intéressent s'y
engagent participent à la lutte contre
ça enfin ça déjà pour moi c'est une des
premières une des premières inquiétudes
que je pense qu'il peut avoir moi je
pense que Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement par exemple ont eu très
peur du mouvement des gilets jaunes à
l'époque
ils ont eu pas très peur des marges pour
le climat même si des gilets jaunes
pourquoi ils ont eu peur des gilets
jaunes parce qu'au moment des gilets
jaunes vous avez des corps de métiers
qui sortent dans la rue vous avez des
gens qui sortent avec leur poids lourds
qui bloquent des routes eh ces gens-là
je veux dire c'est c'est évident quoi
vous avez votre outil de travail et vous
l'utilisez pour un moment mettre à la
LPI parce qu'il y a quelque chose qui
vous gêne
aujourd'hui le mouvement écolo ne
s'était jamais attaqué comme ça à des
infrastructures les soulèvements de la
terre c'est un petit peu protéiforme
vous voyez c'est assez compliqué à
cerner vous avez des gens des villes
vous avez des gens des territoires et
d'un coup vous avez un tas
d'infrastructures qui peuvent paraître
comme ça pris au hasard qu'en réalité ne
le sont pas on le verra plus tard qui
sont atteignables les méga bassines par
exemple à cause de cutter c'est assez
simple et vous avez un ensemble de
personnalités publiques un ensemble de
forces syndicales un ensemble de
mouvements de jeunes donc tout un tas de
gens qui auparavant avaient du mal à
s'allier entre eux ou à faire force
commune qui d'un coup vont taper dans
les territoires un peu partout sur des
campagnes d'action saccadées il y a eu
quand même 30 actions en deux ans donc
au bout d'un moment au début ils ont
laissé faire ils sont dit bon 400
personnes 500 personnes qui vont à
droite à gauche même s'il y a des gestes
intéressants on laisse couler puis au
bout d'un moment quand on passe de 100
personnes à la première manifestation à
30000 en mars sur un projet de bassine
c'est quoi c'est quoi le c'est quoi le
truc quoi donc ils ont dû ils ont
commencé à se dire là il y a quelque
chose qui nous qui nous dépasse quoi
donc à mon sens c'est l'héritage
gilet jaune qui qui reprend en fait des
héritages antérieurs de dire on va aller
cibler précisément
les infrastructures qui sont
problématiques on va montrer par le
geste ce qui est exactement
problématique on développe on développe
plus tard pardon cette idée là
et en même temps un effet de masse on
fait ça avec papi mamie et avec des
gamins un visage découvert et pas qu'à
bien sûr
déterminée bien sûr
on s'expose et nous aussi d'ailleurs
si je peux compléter aussi je pense
qu'il y a
il y a aussi un déplacement de la
fenêtre d'overload d'overton sur sur
notamment vis-à-vis de
du désarmement enfin ou ce que d'autres
personnes veulent du sabotage mais où là
le terme de désarmement je pense on va y
revenir c'est quand même un langage
vachement militaire que vous employez ça
cible ça des armes je te laisse
continuer
justement en fait le terme de
désarmement ce qui ce qu'il a de
particulier c'est qu'il permet de
préciser la cible c'est à dire justement
des armes des armes de destruction
massive du vivant des parce que le terme
de sabotage à vrai dire à la base ce qui
fait c'est qu'il
dans le discours
juridique il dit c'est s'attaquer à des
infrastructures vitales alors que là
justement nous ce qu'on enfin ce que les
soulèvements de la terre pointe c'est
que il y a plein d'infrastructures qui
sont en cours de construction qui sont
des infrastructures qui sont mortifères
qui en fait condamnent toute une
génération qui qui condamne
nos jours futurs et oui Christophe
pourquoi le l'appareil d'État appelle ça
des structures vitales
c'est dans la définition du sabotage que
le sabotage c'est une destruction
d'outils de production qui sont vitaux
au pays
[Musique]
il faut avoir une vision un petit peu
productiviste du monde pour considérer
ça de cette façon c'est à dire que non
on peut avoir au contraire l'impression
que il y a toute une série
d'infrastructures et d'activités de
production qui sont plutôt des outils de
destruction de la planète
dont on est en train de dépasser les
limites planétaires les 1,5 degrés
on va les dépasser avant 2030 voilà la
banquise il y en aura plus en été
probablement autour de 2030 également
c'est une étude qui est parue il y a
moins de trois semaines
une étude de où par qui commet alors
attendez il faut que je retrouve si je
peux compléter du coup parmi le constat
un petit peu que je pense
de début juin 2023
la personne qui travaille au Muséum
d'histoire naturelle qui rappelait que
par rapport précédente extinction
massive là on avait des
c'était des à une vitesse je crois de à
plusieurs enfin 100 fois plus rapide
jusqu'à 1000 fois plus rapide
d'extinction de des espèces quoi c'est
est-ce que tu t'es mis dans la peau de
si je peux me permettre est-ce que tu
t'es mis dans la peau du gestionnaire de
l'État qui voit arriver 30 000 personnes
près de ses bassines où ils sont dit bon
les bassines va peut-être y avoir la
guerre de l'eau il risque d'y avoir des
pénuries de flotte on est obligé de
faire des réserves on va avoir plus de
capacité de stockage pour pouvoir
approvisionner notre chaîne de
production alimentaire et on voit 30 000
débarqués et une petite minorité
ultra ultra violente
si tu te mets dans la peau du
gestionnaire de l'État tu fais de la
préfète
de la préfète tu te dis quoi tu te dis
c'est dangereux parce que ça menace
peut-être ma chaîne d'approvisionnement
alimentaire si tu te dis quoi quand tu
vois arriver ça tu paniques tu paniques
pas tu fais du renseignement ne fais pas
de renseignement comment tu perçois la
chose
j'ai pas beaucoup l'habitude de mettre
dans la peau du gestionnaire de l'État
mais par contre c'est dommage mais par
contre bah de se mettre dans sa peau
pour essayer de détourner les
dispositifs ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
a l'habitude de faire au sein des
soulèvements de la terre mais pas
forcément de ce de se mettre dans leur
dans leur peau depuis leur intérêts par
contre moi j'aime bien me mettre dans la
peau des agriculteurs et des
agriculteurs qui veulent construire des
bassines
est-ce qu'ils sont liés à un système
parce qu'ils sont liés à des
coopératives qui font que ils se disent
il faut continuer à faire du maïs par
exemple ce Mans il faut continuer à
faire même du maïs à l'exporter ou à
faire du blé à l'exporter etc il faut
irriguer ces cultures l'été le problème
en se mettant dans la peau de ces gens
là c'est que nous ce qu'on explique à
travers les soulèvements de la terre et
à travers un tas
d'études qui ont pu finalement être
mises au jour grâce au fait qu'il y a un
mouvement de masse qui les ai qui les ai
révélés qui a été dissous
malheureusement ou heureusement on en
reparlera
moi je me mets dans la peau de ces
agriculteurs et je me dis en fait ce qui
est terrible c'est que les gammes se
rendent pas compte qu'on va leur creuser
leur faire faire des infrastructures qui
vont s'endetter comme d'hab et que c'est
bassines elles vont pas pouvoir être
remplies ce qui a été possible de
montrer grâce au mouvement des
soulèvements de la Terre ce qui était
montré déjà depuis 10 ans par le
collectif bassine non merci petit à
petit c'est qu'en fait le réchauffement
climatique va entraîner le fait que ces
infrastructures là vont être
défaillantes
à partir enfin depuis le début de ces
protocoles de construction d'assines
tous basés sur un rapport du Bureau
d'études géologique et minières
ce rapport il voilà il faisait des
estimations il étudiait si vous voulez
les niveaux des nappes phréatiques les
niveaux des cours d'eau il disait on
peut prélever tant à partir de telles
seuil c'est possible de remplir tant de
bassines et du coup et du coup les
projets étaient faits à partir de là
quand vous vous rendez compte au bout
d'un moment que
l'entièreté de ces bassines ne pourra
pas être remplie que en Espagne vous
avez un une forme de désertification que
vous avez une bassine par exemple celle
de Vivonne qui a une faille et qui n'a
rien qui repousse dessus on pourra
préciser ces choses-là un peu plus tard
vous rendez compte que vous mettez en
fait les gens
vous mettez les gens dans la mer et que
il y a une forme de d'aveuglement et on
pousse
on pousse les projets
à bout on essaye de construire de
construire les choses coûte que coûte
alors qu'en réalité tout démontre
aujourd'hui que ça ne va pas tenir
debout
c'est la seule chose que je peux vous
répondre ne prenez pas en compte le
changement climatique dans son étude ça
y est tout à fait il a été mis à jour
par la contre-expertise qui a été faite
par bassine non merci je pense même que
le terme d'études est peut-être un c'est
même pas une étude scientifique parce
que normalement quand on quand on fait
des études scientifiques c'est validé
par les Pères c'est à dire que c'est
c'est vraiment relu par des gens etc qui
valident le travail là ça n'a pas été le
cas il y avait des erreurs vraiment
en termes de d'approximation d'erreurs
etc à l'intérieur le le rapport a été
désarmé par Anne Morwen j'ai oublié de
nom de famille mais
tout à fait
qui qui voilà qui donc c'est son domaine
d'expertise et elle a bien montré en
fait à quel point cette étude qui en
fait je pense même le terme d'études à
vrai dire et peut-être trop pour pour ce
travail là même je crois que le bergm
c'est retirer après pour dire non non
faut pas s'appuyer sur ces travaux là
pour pour valider pour valider le fait
pense que les méga bassines c'est une
bonne idée il y a également aussi un
autre rapport qui a été fait
le rapport du
H CUG
urologie milieu usage climat HM UC
pardon oui tout à fait et où ça
là-dessus je sais pas si tu veux en dire
un mot ou pour continuer sur le rapport
du BRGM si vous voulez aujourd'hui vous
avez des rapports qui sont dit
scientifiques vous avez la Coop de l'eau
79 qui commande un rapport pour savoir
si elle peut faire des bassines dans le
marais poitevin d'accord parce qu'il y a
besoin d'iriguer fort l'été en pleine
période en pleine période où il fait le
plus chaud vous avez certaines cultures
qui demandent une irrigation en réalité
vous avez quand même
la vous avez quand même que 6% des
terres qui sont irrigués l'été donc
c'est en dans
le domaine agricole c'est quand même une
toute petite partie
vous avez un rapport qui est commandé
par la Coop de l'eau 79 et qui demande
en fait pour construire finalement ces
infrastructures combien on va pouvoir
prélever c'est quoi les seuils qui qui
essayent de prélèvement qui sont permis
donc voyez depuis où la science est
faite depuis quelle question la science
est faite c'est ça qu'on veut
questionner aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est
pas un rapport neutre c'est une commande
c'est une commande ce rapport votre avis
c'est une commande
non c'est une commande de la Coop 79
d'accord
cette commande donc elle est faite le
rapport est fait et ensuite vous avez
des hydrologues de bassines non merci
qui regarde et qui disent en fait tous
les cours d'eau minoritaires ne sont pas
pris en compte dans ce rapport d'accord
donc vous avez que les cours d'eau
majoritaires or l'infiltration de l'eau
dans les sols et dans les nappes
phréatiques c'est lié à toutes les
siniosités à tout en fait à toute la
multiplicité des cours d'eau que vous
avez sur un territoire territoire qui
était la plus grande la deuxième plus
grande zone humide d'Europe avant d'être
peu à peu drainé pour l'agriculture
industrielle d'accord
deuxièmement le rapport ne prend pas en
compte le réchauffement climatique ça
c'est pas grave non je rigole vous vous
rendez compte petit à petit avec les
sécheresses
avec les sécheresses
dont celle de l'hiver 2022 2023 et qui
est inédite avec les trois quarts des
nappes
sur le département qui sont dans cette
critique
en fait ce rapport il ne tient plus la
route et vous avez posé une question oui
comment ça se fait qu'une boulangerie
bûcheronne parle mieux qu'une politique
je sais pas pourquoi pourquoi tu t'es
intéressé à tout ça
pourquoi je me suis intéressé à tout ça
parce que en allant chercher du bois tu
t'es rendu compte qu'il y avait plus
d'espèces invasives tu t'es rendu compte
que le bois poussé moins vite de
meilleure qualité de moins bonne qualité
est-ce que comment tu as eu le déclic de
t’intéresser à tout ça par exemple dans
le bûcheronnage je me suis intéressé
d'avoir effectivement la question
forestière avant avant ces questions là
la question de l'eau par exemple c'est
un peu nouveau quoi je me suis intéressé
avec les soulèvements de la terre moi je
connaissais pas de marais poitevin je me
suis rendu quelque fois parce que il y
avait des gens intéressants aussi là-bas
qui avaient qui avait de la bouteille
sur leur territoire après le
bûcheronnage par exemple
je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
essayaient de faire un modèle agricole
en forêt quoi donc ils essayaient de
faire des il faisait des plantations de
Douglas des pisséa en rang et qu'en fait
c'est plantations monoculture couperase
elle devenait de moins en moins
résistante par exemple aux épices enfin
le colis qui rentre dans l'épica tout
crève aujourd'hui les forestiers c'est
tout le monde tout le monde s'affole
l'OMF il faut il faut il va falloir
reboiser avec des nouvelles essences qui
viennent du sud tout ça toutes les
forêts françaises chez nous le sapin
pectiné tout le monde dit qu'il va
crever parce que parce que c'est un
arbre qui demande beaucoup d'humilité
etc donc je me suis rendu compte de
système industriel absurde en forêt
c'est presque pire qu'en agriculture
parce que
les mecs ils ont voulu faire quelque
chose la forêt c'est le système le plus
productif qui existe les arbres ils
poussent vous pouvez les les élaguer
vous pouvez
entretenir en forêt directement mais
mais c'est très très productif donc on
peut récolter du bois sans dépenser
d'argent en plantant en allant passer la
débroussailleuse en mettant de l'engrais
etc comme ils font maintenant donc vous
avez des abattes qui sont subventionnés
vous avez des plantations qui sont
subventionnées et vous avez un système
économique qui qui tourne à l'envers
alors qu'en fait en laissant évoluer les
milieux en venant prélever petit à petit
dans des forêts diversifiées qui sont
beaucoup plus résistantes aux impacts
qu'elles vont subir que ce soit
réchauffement climatique attaque de
champignons attaques de parasites etc et
ben finalement vous en sortez beaucoup
mieux
et voilà moi je suis rentré c'est une
des manières dont je suis dans je suis
rentré dans tout ça après je me suis
beaucoup intéressé au combat de notre
âme des Landes à l'époque aussi
je peux donner la parole à Christophe
Christophe quand on entend
petit à petit est-ce que le capitalisme
peut tolérer le petit à petit est-ce que
prendre le temps
c'est pas contre-productif pour le
capitalisme
l'histoire de la foresterie il y a toute
une science de rationalisation
forestière pour déterminer à quel moment
c'est le mieux de couper parce que les
arbres poussent très vite au début et
moins vite au bout d'un certain âge et
donc déjà au 18e siècle des agronomes
économistes de la physiocratie ou Buffon
calcul à quel âge c'est le plus rentable
de couper la forêt et comment on va
l'organiser par parcelle en coupant une
par une les parcelles et puis en
tournant selon la l'âge du cycle
souhaité
le premier type de calcul c'est
effectivement le moment où ça pousse un
peu moins vite c'est le moment il faut
couper et puis vers un calcul financier
s'il y a un pourcentage de temps de
croissance du bois par an
parfois ça peut être intéressant de
couper encore un tout petit peu avant
que le moment où ça sera lentille parce
que à ce moment-là la croissance de la
forêt est un peu inférieure au rendement
financier du capital si on le mettait
ailleurs et donc depuis le 18e siècle au
moins la rationalité financière et
devenue dominante dans la foresterie
industrielle ça c'est évident mais
peut-être moi je voulais rebondir sur
l'Espagne on a parlé de l'exemple
espagnol il a été invoqué y compris par
la présidente de la FNSEA en 2020 qui
disait ben voilà en France on utilise
seulement
on capte uniquement 1,7% de la pluie qui
tombe sur le territoire alors qu'en
Espagne c'est 20%
faudrait que je cherche bosser une
citation de la présidente de la FNSE en
2020 c'est un argument qui a été invoqué
également dans un débat à la télé il y a
pas très longtemps par une géographie
Sylvie brune Bruno Brunier pardon
et donc il y aura l'idée qu'on serait en
retard par rapport à l'Espagne tu es
l'Espagne se débrouille mieux
effectivement depuis Franco dans les
années 50 des politiques d'aménagement
le béton a été très important dans la
construction du fascisme espagnol il y a
eu des travaux d'histoire là-dessus on a
créé des milliers de barrages et 1200 et
quelques 1226 bassine
le problème c'est que toute cette
ensemble d'aménagement y compris un
canal qui va du Tage à la fois en plein
air et souterrain jusqu'à la région
d'Almeria où il y a des serres
intensives où on fait des tomates les
fraises etc qui sont exportées dans
toute l'Europe le bilan c'est décennies
d'aménagement hydraulique c'est que on a
une aridification de l'Espagne qui
résiste pas au changement climatique on
a 3 millions d'hectares agricoles qui
ont été perdus à cause de cette de cette
aridification et puis ça c'est des des
articles qui sont sortis dans Mediapart
et reporters au mois d'avril par là
50% des bassines qui a les bassines
actuelles les 1200 bassines sont remplis
à 50% c'est à dire qu'il y a plus il
pleut plus assez pour remplir les
bassines et donc j'avais compris qu'il
tapait aussi dans les nappes phréatiques
et on est typiquement dans ce que le
GIEC appelle une malade adaptation dans
le dernier rapport du GIEC du groupe 3
il y a l'idée voilà face au
réchauffement climatique il y a des
solutions qui paraissent comme ça
pratiquent à court terme et pour
quelques-uns
mais qui sont les regarde à plus long
terme on s'aperçoit que elles sont
néfastes elles sont injustes ou elles
affaiblissent notre capacité
d'adaptation et de résilience donc c'est
la définition du terme adaptation les
bassines et l'expérience espagnole le
monde sont un exemple de malade
adaptation alors moi comme historien ça
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que le
charbon est une malade adaptation
au début du 19e siècle les forestiers
le problème écologique numéro 1 de
l'Europe de l'Ouest au 18e au tournant
du 18e et 19e siècle c'est la
déforestation on avait à peu près
un tiers du couvert forestier de
l'Europe de l'Ouest qui a disparu entre
le 16ème et le 18e siècle et on sait à
l'époque d'une part en montagne ça
augmente l'érosion les catastrophes les
glissements de terrain etc et d'autre
part il y a des théories climatiques qui
disent que moins il y a de forêt plus le
climat est sec et chaud et ces théories
climatiques sont déjà globales elles
sont portées par des gens comme Buffon
etc on explique le fait que Bordeaux est
plus chaud que Montréal alors que c'est
à la même latitude par le fait qu'au
Canada il y a plein de forêts parce que
les Indiens sont des sauvages ils sont
des chasseurs cueilleurs ils ont pas
vraiment mis en valeur leur milieu donc
c'est froid alors que nous les Européens
nous avons la charrue nous avons cultivé
notre territoire et donc nous avons un
climat plus tempéré donc il y a déjà
l'idée que les forêts jouent un rôle de
régulation du climat à grande échelle et
donc la déforestation d'une part le prix
du bois augmente très fort dans la fin
du XVIIIe siècle et d'autre part on a
peur des modifications climatiques il y
a des années un peu exceptionnelles dans
les années 1815 1816 c'est le volcan
Pina tout beau qui provoque on sait pas
que c'est le vote quand à l'époque il y
a divers dérèglements climatiques et on
va se mettre à accuser la déforestation
et un salon de forestiers disent bah
pour préserver nos forêts extrayant du
charbon
ça va nous permettre de de laisser nos
beaux paysages de préserver notre bon
climat en s'appuyant sur une nouvelle
ressource souterraine qui finalement
n'est pas dangereuse donc quelque part
le charbon c'est la technologie verte et
la maladie adaptation du début du 19e
siècle qui nous fait entrer dans la
société fossile et un deuxième exemple
de mal adaptation c'est les OGM certes
les OGM apparaissent dans les années 70
avec la promesse de nous délivrer du
choc pétrolier il y a le choc pétrolier
de 73 tout à coup les agriculteurs sont
endettés l'engrais coûte plus cher ce
que l'engrais fait à base de enfin il
faut beaucoup d'énergie pour réunir pour
transformer la zone de l'air en azote
assimilable par les plantes
le pétrole qu'on met dans les tracteurs
coûte plus cher les agriculteurs sont
endettés les prix de l'alimentation
augmentent on a des famines au sel dans
les années 74 75 et il y a la promesse
que
en améliorant génétiquement les plantes
on va peut-être réussir à faire des
céréales qui vont directement fixer
l'azote
on va mettre des gènes de l'agro
bactérium qui est la bactérie qui fixe
l'azote on va les transférer dans le blé
et puis avec un peu de quelques
promesses de plus on nous promet que
dans les années 80-90 on aura des
céréales qui auront plus besoin
d'engrais on nous promet qu'on aura des
céréales résistantes aux maladies que en
plus besoin de pesticides et si vous
lisez moi j'ai travaillé là-dessus les
rapports de biotechnologue et même de la
DG RST du ministère de la recherche de
l'époque on nous promet ça or 25 ans
plus tard qu'est-ce qui se passe les
principaux OGM qui sont sur le marché
sont pas du tout économe ni en intrant à
sauter ni en pesticide mais sont au
contraire tolérant à ces pesticides et
les compagnies semencières qui qui
diffusent ces semences sont en même
temps propriétaire des brevets sur les
pesticides en question donc on a un
verrouillage technologique qui s'est
fait alors qu'auparavant nous avait
promis de nous libérer des problèmes du
choc énergétique et de la crise
écologique des années 70 donc moi en
tant qu'historien j'ai une longue série
d'exemples comme ça de promesses de
solution verte qui se terminent en mal
adaptation et j'ai le sentiment je
pourrais pas le prouver de façon carré
cubique j'ai le sentiment que les
bassines nous amènent vers le même type
de mal adaptation que les exemples que
j'ai donné
je peux te poser une question il y a pas
le droit
est-ce que tu veux rebondir là dessus
oui moi je voulais peut-être rajouter
des petits éléments sur sur les
megabassines parce que aussi ce qui a
permis de faire en sorte que il y a plus
de 30 000 personnes à Sainte-Souline
c'est aussi le fait qu'il y a eu des
réunions publiques qui ont été
organisées un peu partout et je faisais
partie des personnes qui du coup ont
organisé des réunions publiques sur la
question des méga bassines
et donc du coup je pense que c'est hyper
important de rappeler effectivement que
c'est pas de l'eau de pluie parce que si
c'était de l'eau de pluie ce serait ça
mettrait 15 ans à se remplir et ça c'est
même sans compter l'évaporation ça il y
a un rapport du CNRS qui est sorti cette
année qui disait que l'évaporation des
méga bassines c'était entre 20 et 60%
d'évaporation
mais ça empêche pas la prolifération de
bactéries de enfin voilà il y a c'est et
et rappelez aussi que tu tapes de l'eau
des nappes phréatiques qui est censé est
une bonne flotte pour consommer tu le
mets dans la bassine et là tu as tout un
tas de bactéries qui peuvent se
développer
une aberration de l'eau qui est dans les
quais dans les nappes phréatiques de la
laisser à l'air alerte comme ça se faire
évaporer se dégrader etc enfin c'est
c'est peut-être rappelé aussi le du coup
le rôle des nappes phréatiques juste une
question oui le fond de la bassine il
est en quoi en plastique il y a un
transfert de du plastique à l'eau pas
genre est-ce que le goût composé de de
du plastique va se retrouver dans la
flotte parce que ça chauffe un peu
je fais mon bébé aussi je connais pas du
tout les bassines ça là-dessus moi je
sais pas ce serait peut-être intéressant
en tout cas dès qu'il y a de l'eau qui
est en contact avec du plastique
normalement il y a de enfin
est-ce que je peux ajouter quelque chose
avant que le mouvement
avant que le mouvement des soulèvements
de la Terre existe il y avait déjà un
collectif bâti non merci qui existait et
ce qui se racontait en dehors de ce
collectif bah sinon merci dans l'opinion
publique par le gouvernement la FNSEA la
Coop de l'eau c'était que sébacine
allait se remplir avec l'eau de pluie on
entendait ça de partout il a fallu
marteler marteler marteler faire un
certain nombre de manifestations pour
prouver que non ça ne se remplissait pas
seulement avec de l'eau de pluie et
qu'on allait pomper dans les nappes
phréatiques qu'est-ce qu'on a fait pour
ça et un jour il y a une manifestation
des soulèvements de la terre c'était la
deuxième il me semble dans le marais
poitevin où on est allé à
mauzé-sur-lignon qui avait été rebaptisé
mozé-sur-bassine pour l'occasion la
préfecture interdit tout vous aviez des
interdictions territoire de partout la
manifestation part
elle au lieu de viser une première
bassine elle se elle est empêchée par un
dispositif holicier et du coup elle fait
demi-tour elle passe dans le lit du
mignon qui est la rivière de là-bas et
elle débarque sur la bassine de mauzée
sur le mignon qui a appelé sev17 dans le
dans le langage technique
la bassine est débâchée et là vous avez
le porte-parole de la Confédération
paysanne
et d'autres gens qui vont démonter la
pompe
qui sert à alimenter cette bassine la
pompe elle est portée elle est montrée à
la foule et ils vont décider d'aller
l'emmener au ministère de l'agriculture
c'est pour vous dire que le but des
soulèvements de la terre dans une époque
où tout le monde parle
soulèvement de la terre absolue c'est
qu'en fait vous allez faire un geste qui
va faire preuve vous voyez à l'époque où
tout le monde dit ah oui les bassines se
remplissent par de l'eau depuis et en
face et les gens ah non les bassines se
remplissent par par pompage dans les
nappes phréatiques nous on a estimé à un
moment qui avait besoin de gens qui
aillent sur les infrastructures et qui a
éprouver la réalité et pourquoi casser
c'est pas cassé c'est ce que je vous dis
vous êtes un moment où le débat il est
aussi fait les gens ne s'écoutent pas
vous avez l'impression que les gens
s'écoutent aujourd'hui
il y a énormément de publications de
partout de vidéos de réseaux sociaux etc
si vous n'allez pas montrer en sur place
dans les territoires concernés avec les
gens des territoires concernés et
d'autres gens qui les soutiennent et des
syndicats et des public les choses vous
n’êtes pas entendu et on l'a prouvé avec
les soulèvements de la terre petit à
petit en deux ans ça veut dire enlever
toute la pellicule de plastique et au
fond de la bassine c'est ça
vous mettez des coups de cutter dans le
dans la phrase dans le plastique quoi
c'est les bâches combien ça coûte une
bassine
que sur le projet qui avait du coup à
l'échelle à l'échelle des Deux Sèvres
sur le projet de 16 bassines il me
semble que le coût estimé à la base
était à 60 millions d'euros mais il a
été revu à la hausse notamment pour des
frais de gardiennage ou d'assurance
liées à des potentiels venus de
personnes qui lutte contre alors moi je
vous pose une question
pourquoi vous neutralisez pas les
éléments les plus délités et violents
qui s'approchent des bassines
est-ce que vous avez un service de
sécurité est-ce que vous avez compris le
côté
contre-productif d'avoir des gens qui
cartonnent les la police ça coûte
cocktail Molotov de caillasses de
cocktail à l'acide de cocktail au boulon
qui se baladent avec des lance-pierre
qui se baladent avec des cutter est-ce
que vous allez un point de vue sur cette
violence là est-ce que la lutte
écologique peut se passer de la violence
selon vous oui ou non qui prend la
parole Christophe ou Marcel
moi je veux bien non Christophe ou
Marcel
alors Adèle
non si vous voulez le problème et
soulèvement de la Terre vous commencez
un mouvement et vous dites si on en a
marre d'être impuissant c'est pas
possible on va pas défiler dans la rue a
demandé la baisse des missions de CO2 il
n'écouter rien pourquoi tu as fait une
grève de la fin
et
du coup puisque c'est pas forcément ça
nous paraît pas forcément efficace des
grèves de la faim
vous allez manifester un certain nombre
d'endroits dans des races campagnes et
vous avez face à vous des interdictions
de manifester vous arrivez quand même à
rassembler du monde c'est-à-dire que les
gens
sont relativement déterminés il nous
interdit de manifester parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas qui est une mise en question
qui est un trouble dans le dans
l'exécution d'un certain nombre de
projets
sur le mignon par exemple elle était
illégale elle était en fonction
fonctionnelle
utiliser mais illégal donc à un moment
quand vous n'avez rien qui est respecté
vous allez sur place et vous allez et
vous allez montrer que ce sont des
projets en de manière générale qui vont
privatiser
soi-même
c'est comme si moi je veux sinon ça je
vais pas arriver au bout je vois une
paillote sur la plage ça privatise le
domaine public je débarque pas avec ma
hache et mes copains pour démonter la
paillote non alors nous on est sur un
mouvement construit avec un certain
nombre d'arguments un certain nombre de
composantes voilà il y a une
signification on n'est pas en train de
se faire justice soi-même
attire la Rigot
donc vous connaissez la police française
nous ça fait un certain nombre d'années
que le les différentes composantes des
soulèvements de la terre ont quand même
l'habitude de manifester et on sait
qu'on reçoit dans des foules compact
c'était encore le cas à la dernière
manifestation des soulèvements de la
terre avec une foule compacte sur un
poux qui jetait des bouts de cailloux
comme ça à des moments sur sur les
forces de l'ordre qui reçoit des
grenades des encerclantes qui reçoit des
grenades assourdissantes et vous voyez
des gens qui repartent en civière et qui
se sont fait exploser les pieds avec
voilà donc au bout d'un moment la police
française est en Skelet vous avez des
gens en face vous avez des gens en face
qui qui réagissent
alors moi j'ai pas vu des bouts de
caillou j'ai vu des cocktails Molotov
j'ai eu des gars qui se baladaient avec
quand même quelque chose qui ressemblait
de la guérilla en tout cas nous on ne va
jamais se dissocier de personnes qui à
un moment se défendent contre des armes
de guerre qui leur sont tiraient dessus
la police c'est le tire pas si elle
reçoit pas même des petits bouts de
cailloux
des soulèvements de la terre qui a
dégénéré sans que la police ne jette des
grenades sur les manifestants vous
regardez quatre Toulouse l'action a été
sans heure vous regardez saint
colombants l'action a été 100 heures oui
je suis désolé mais c'est quand même des
sujets sensibles nous on a eu après
certaines manifestations des gens qui
finissent dans le coma donc on n'est pas
quand vous faites partie du mouvement
peu importe l'endroit où vous êtes
dedans c'est c'est quand même des sujets
là on ressort de de d'une séquence ou
on a regardé à la télé des nuits
d'émeutes fait par des jeunes il y a eu
enfin voilà l'histoire de Noël enfin je
suis désolé de m'emporter un peu mais
c'est quand même des sujets qui sont qui
sont légèrement sensibles on va dire
Marcel Christophe je vois Christophe que
les gens croisaient les bras croisés
la violence historiquement parlant
est-ce que on peut lutter sans violence
historiquement en fait la plupart des
luttes qui nous ont libérés qui ont
amélioré la condition humaine ont été un
mélange de tactiques légalises et
d'action direct
on peut commencer par l'esclavage on
n'est pas sorti de l'esclavage juste
parce qu'il y a des parlementaires de la
deuxième république qui ont aboli
l'esclavage en 48 on est sorti de
l'esclavage parce qu'il y avait la
révolution Haïti parce qu'il y a des
esclaves marrons qui ont incendié des
plantations et parfois tuer des
planteurs
aussi parce que la puissance anglaise
qui était la grande puissance du 19e
siècle a posé ça aux autres puissances
dans le traité de Vienne de 1815 et ils
avaient une flotte qui était spécialisée
dans la résonnement des navires
portugais espagnol hollandais et
français qui sortaient de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest donc ça c'est pas fait juste par
des pétitions ou
quelque chose de d'humanitaire on aurait
progressivement pris conscience on est
sorti de la traite atlantique par des
luttes qui ont été parfois violentes
premièrement si on regarde les
mouvements sociaux ouvriers
le congé payé le jour de repos
hebdomadaire en France il a été conquis
en 1906 après l'accident de Courrières
qui a un accident dans une mine dans le
Nord il y a un effondrement plus de 1000
mineurs qui meurent une protestation
grève massive affrontement avec la
police il y a un officier de police qui
meurt mais c'était un moment d'émotion
tellement importante cet accident que
derrière il y a eu des conquêtes
sociales et la journée de repos
hebdomadaire qui a été conquise si on
regarde les droits civiques aux
États-Unis c'est pas que Luther King il
y avait Luther King mais il y avait les
Black plantaires c'est cette diversité
de mode d'action qui un rapport de force
qui fait peur à des personnes au pouvoir
qui se disent bon aller d'accord on va
lâcher quelque chose et voilà on
pourrait multiplier les exemples de
lutte dans l'histoire le mouvement
féministe les suffragettes le droit de
vote c'est pas conquis uniquement par
des manifestations et ses contiers par
des bombes au début du 20e siècle en
Angleterre les suffragettes envoyaient
des bombes par courrier donc la question
qu'on peut se poser je sais pas si vous
connaissez le capital au 21e siècle de
Thomas Piketty il a des courbes qui
m'ont fait flipper qui m'ont saisi il
regarde la part du capital privé au sens
large moyen de production et propriété
individuelles des riches par rapport au
PIB de chaque année
et dans les périodes les plus hautes où
le capital à la place la plus importante
sur la société on est à 7 fois le PIB en
1788 en 1913 et aujourd'hui et puis
après la Révolution française ça baisse
ça tombe à 3-4 fois puis ça remonte
jusqu'en 1913 après il y a les deux
guerres la crise de 29 et la
redistribution des années fordistes et
keynésienne des années 50 et finalement
on s'aperçoit que les deux fois où les
possédants ont été convaincus de lâcher
un peu du l'Est et de redistribuer un
peu de l'argent c'est après la
révolution de 89 qui a pas été
une partie plaisir il y a eu pas mal de
guillotinés de guerre etc et après les
grandes boucheries du milieu du 20e
siècle quand même la Première Guerre
mondiale la crise de 29 la révolution en
Union soviétique la deuxième guerre
mondiale et le Coste certes il faut
malheureusement
on s'aperçoit dans l'histoire pour que
les élites du capital partagent un petit
peu d'argent dans l'histoire ça n'a
jamais été sans
boucherie malheureusement j'aimerais
bien que ça se passe sans boucherie la
prochaine fois j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on
les convaincre c'est quoi les élites
c'est justement les possédants de cette
part du capital que mesure Thomas
Piketty
sur la violence il y a
on ne dissout pas un soulèvement sur la
notion de violence et sur la notion de
contrevolence aussi et je pense que
c'est toujours nécessaire de rappeler
donc dedans il y a une citation de
l'évêque camarade qui rappelle les trois
formes de violence c'est-à-dire la
première qui est celle qui est celle de
l'État en fait qui broie les corps qui
est systémique etc la seconde qui est
qui peut être celle qui est appelée
contre violence mais que la violence en
fait des personnes qui qui se défendent
face à ça qui luttent de la violence
révolutionnaire et la troisième qui va
être la violence répressive et je pense
que voilà c'est c'est il y a rien de
plus
le fait de qualifier uniquement la
seconde forme de violence c'est c'est il
y a rien de plus et par ailleurs les
soulèvements de la terre quand vous
faites les manifestations le but est
toujours de déjouer le dispositif
positif jamais de le rencontrer
frontalement alors et une ou deux fois
on a été mis vraiment dans des
situations où on nous attend voilà la
vidéo vous étiez pourchasser avec des
quads voilà
chez Daktari avec des LBD comme ça mais
sinon le but est à Sainte Soline ça
avait marché la première fois c'est de
contourner un dispositif donc là vous
êtes dans un rugby à ciel ouvert vous
êtes avec moi ce jour là j'étais dans le
cortège blanc donc dans le cortège
familial avec les vieux les jeunes les
enfants et tout ce que vous voulez le
cortège qui visait la bassine donc il y
avait tout droit et vous avez des lignes
comme ça de de policiers dans en race
campagne quoi une scène de film quoi et
en fait on les fixé comme dans un rugby
et puis on détournait on les a passés en
faisant des lignes comme ça en farandole
en leur disant que en fait ils avaient
été détournés par d'autres cortèges qui
étaient passés qui étaient passés avant
nous donc le but c'est toujours de
trouver la manière la plus maline
d'arriver là où on veut arriver et
jamais d'aller sans plafrer contre un
dispositif qui de toute façon va nous
blesser et va nous va nous faire
beaucoup plus de mal que que ce qui lui
est envoyé comme comme
on est tous d'accord
on a des drones on a la 5G partout on a
l'Internet la surveillance de masse on a
une loi qui vient de tomber pour pouvoir
pister qui que quoi quand comment avec
votre téléphone portable avec injection
de de petites choses sur votre téléphone
qui pourraient qui recours circuiter ce
que vous utiliseriez pour passer sous le
radar est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression que votre perception de la
lutte et un caduc contre productive et
ne fait que renforcer les gens qui en
face
moi je dirais que non parce que
justement c'est pas une conception
avant-gardiste où il y aurait je sais
pas je pense à la zone du dehors le
livre d'Alain Damasio qui est un auteur
que j'adore on a 5 grands chefs mal
révolutionnaires qu'il faut mentent un
complot etc les soulèvements de la terre
c'est pas ça c'est un mouvement de masse
ou les actions se font à ciel ouvert ça
ressemble plus au mouvement des
faucheurs des années 90 ou certes il y a
eu des fauchages de nuit qui étaient qui
en destin par des petits groupes mais il
y a eu des fauchasses de jour avec des
élus en écharpe avec ça et donc il y a
une dimension de pédagogie d'éducation
populaire dans les modes d'action qui
sont choisis et donc on est à la fois
dans une action qui évidemment c'est
pour l'instant
pour moi la question c'est que à la fois
on peut dire que c'est une minorité
active ces travaux de moscovicii dans
les années 70 les minorités actives
changent le monde etc et en même temps
on ne se prétend pas
une avant-garde qui va changer le monde
à la place des gens il y a une volonté
de majorité culturelle et de gagner
l'ensemble de la population à un désir
de vivre autrement de vivre mieux avec
moins de vivre de façon plus autonome et
moins centralisé voilà on a je comprends
pas exactement le sens de ta question en
fait parce que vous c'est-à-dire que sur
la question en amont parce que tu dis
oui maintenant on a les smartphones des
drones des trucs tout le monde dépister
mais en attendant il y a besoin quand
même de boire de la flotte enfin nous en
fait c'est de remettre de de redire
l'avenir agricole de la France il est
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui est
très complexe il y a la moitié des
agriculteurs qui vont partir à la
retraite dans les 10 ans à venir il y a
un quart des terres qui vont changer de
main
la question de l'eau potable ça va
devenir une question tendue ces
prochaines années nous on ramène les
gens assez réalité là et du coup c'est
bien d'avoir des smartphones des drones
on est surveillé etc mais en attendant
ça fait pas que ces questions là elles
sont youyou c'est des questions de base
en fait donc bien entendu ces questions
fondamentales comment on fait pour
donner à boire à sa population comment
on fait pour donner à manger à sa
population comment on fait pour que sa
population n'est pas froid et puisse
dormir sous un toit les préoccupations
des gens qui me dirigent il y a trois
repas qui nous séparent de la révolte et
de la Révolution
e dispositionnent en disant s'ils n'ont
pas à boire ils ont pas à manger on est
sur une fonction exponentielle les Yuyu
comme tu dis qui nous ennuient
à enlever notre
infrastructure vitale pour pouvoir
continuer ça c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils ont essayé de dire hola est-ce
qu'il y a eu des dialogues directement
avec eux est-ce que vous avez discuté
avec le préfet avec des hommes
politiques avec Emmanuel Macron est-ce
que vous avez eu un dialogue avant ça
disons que toutes les les soulèvements
de la terre c'est pas une organisation
centralisée ce n'était pas
administrativement dissous
c'était pas si vous voulez une
organisation centralisée c'est-à-dire
que chaque action est organisée par une
coordination par une coordination
d'action
qui comprend des collectifs locaux qui
étudient le sujet qui font de la
contre-expertise par exemple sur le
dossier des bassines bah sinon merci la
Confédération paysanne qui a un syndicat
agricole
qui a sa place dans les chambres
d'agriculture et dans les dans les
affaires
des groupes comme des associations
environnementales comme Fna par exemple
et il y a même un certain nombre de
partis politiques qui sont venus en fait
aux manifestations etc quelle partie
politique
sont venus par intérêt je pense ou pas
voilà
pourquoi il y avait pas le Front
national ou s'il y avait pas les
républicains je continue mon
raisonnement
[Musique]
donc chacune de ces composantes si vous
voulez par exemple la Confédération
paysanne a participé
à une commission pour rédiger une
nouvelle politique agricole commune ce
qui est fondamental en France elle a
proposé des lois foncières les tous les
tous les projets sur lesquels les
soulèvements de la terre se sont
mobilisés ont connu des batailles
juridiques avant qu'on vient de se
mobiliser par qui pays comment par des
associations environnementales comme
France
je sais pas par des dons par des
associations encore quelques subventions
oui encore quelques subventions donc si
vous voulez c'est ces rapports là ils
existent et à chaque fois après je
laisserai la parole à Christophe là
dessus
ou à Marcel sur sur chaque
sur un certain nombre de projets on
demande des moratoires il y a un
précédent avec les
OGM là dessus ou il y avait eu une
obtention de l'arrêt de l'interdiction
des
OGM en France et aujourd'hui on
redemande ça sur un certain nombre de
politiques qui nous semblent
ne pas être tout simplement réalisable
les bassines qui ne vont pas se remplir
ou les routes qui coûtent trop cher et
qui artificialisent des terres agricoles
dont on a besoin pour l'avenir
donc en ce sens là il y a des rapports
avec avec des échelles institutionnelles
un peu plus hautes et puis il y a
toujours des rapports avec les mairies
les collectivités territoriales les
les
coopératives qui enfin par exemple dans
le marais poitevin vous avez des
commissions qui travaillent sur l'eau
etc donc oui il y a des il y a des
rapports dérivés je dirais avec avec des
institutions
quand j'entends Adèle elle est en train
de me décrire je vais caricaturer avec
votre ton autorisation
si une flèche mobilisation flashmob sous
stéroïdes avec un bel emballage
si en face il y a la police ou les gens
sont ces protéger les l'argent public et
investi dans des bassines ou censés
protéger X ou Y route
ils se disent là on est au 21e siècle
ils sont capables de communiquer sur les
réseaux sociaux sont peut-être
influencés par les jeux vidéos ils sont
capables de se mobiliser très rapidement
et en plus je vais dire c'est con ils
sont nombreux et au milieu de tout ça il
y a une minorité un peu en mode pointe
de diamant qui est capable de lancer des
cocktails monotov des cailloux qu'on des
lance-pier qu'on décuteurs ça va nous
servir on va pouvoir discréditer tout
l'intégralité du mouvement parce que
vous comprenez il y a quand même des
zinzins qui est capable de faire
beaucoup de violence
la peur de la police de la flèche mob de
30000 personnes qui débarquent est-ce
que vous l'entendez
moi ce que j'entends surtout c'est la
peur quand même de toute une génération
à laquelle je m'identifie
on peut appeler voilà la génération de
mouvement climat etc où ça fait en fait
ça fait des années que on n'est pas du
tout entendu il y a eu des marches où il
y a vraiment eu des un nombre
incalculable de personnes qui sont
descendus dans la rue en demandant un
état d'urgence climatique qui n'ont pas
été entendus et moi vraiment j'ai peur
en fait j'ai vraiment peur de de ce qui
va de que ce soit à la fois de la
biodiversité du réchauffement climatique
de tout ce qui va se passer par la suite
et du coup ces personnes qui sont là en
fait c'est justement parce qu'elles
n'ont pas été entendues pendant des
années que il y a une convention climat
ou on nous avait promis la démarche
était intéressante de voilà de réunir
150 personnes à qui on allait qu'on
allait acquis on allait enseigner plein
de choses et à laquelle on avait demandé
de prendre des décisions le président
avait promis que il retiendrait la
quasi-totalité il bien retenu enfin il y
a eu vraiment enfin je pense qu'il faut
voilà repartir de toute cette historique
pour comprendre ce qui fait que il y a
autant de personnes qui sont mobilisées
et que les personnes sont prêtes
effectivement à
des enjeux d'autodéfense également comme
comme Adèle la rappeler
de nouveau je verrai insister sur le
fait que la France il y a vraiment une
une spécificité sur la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre ou normalement dans
les autres pays d'Europe normalement on
dit ok c'est pas grave s'il y a de la
dégradation matérielle l'importance
c'est ce qui est important ça va être
l'intégrité physique des gens et là en
France c'est clairement pas le cas mais
ça allait au point même où à Sainte
Soline donc la deuxième fois où les
soulèvements de la terre sont allés à
Sainte Soline la la méga bassine qui
était défendue
il y avait même pas de bâche dedans il y
avait rien à dégrader il y avait pas de
il y avait même pas de personnes avec
des cutter qui était prête à la série
dommage parce qu'il y avait pas de bâche
dedans donc là on a même dépassé un
point où c'est même pas ils sont prêts
et c'est même pas qui sont prêts à tuer
pour protéger des infrastructures
matérielles mais c'est qu'ils sont prêts
à tuer pour c'est des armes qui sont
censées
des armes
déjà eu des morts
létales les Suisses disent que le LBD
c'est une arme de guerre alors juste
pour finir ma phrase ma phrase d'avant
que du coup là ils étaient prêts donc à
tuer et bien a tué pour un symbole pour
que
alors du coup allons sur et ben ça a
failli c'était vraiment il y a eu trois
personnes il y a eu deux personnes dans
l'entremar trois personnes qui ont
Chaillé
je me fais l'avocat du diable du côté du
côté de la police bon il y avait un
mauvais angle le vent il courait vers la
balle non pas on a bien vu dans les la
vidéo ou la personne dit hein c'était le
mauvais cortège bah oui c'était le
mauvais cortège enfin on voit bien déjà
totalement indiscriminé
sur le cortège familial
qui est en train d'essayer de faire une
chaîne humaine
les Black Blocs etc les tirs allaient à
peu près à 100 mètres là où il y avait
plutôt les gens qui étaient pas des
spécialistes des militants
professionnels et non on peut penser que
le but c'était de nous donner une leçon
là que la police cherche un peu
gentiment quand il y a des gens qui sont
dans le coma et qui en fait quand on
regarde les gilets jaunes
un peu après
attention je vais me fâcher
donc quand on regarde les gilets jaunes
qui a eu une politique de maintien de
l'ordre digne d'un pays du tiers-monde à
faire des headshots
c'est à dire s'annutile c'est
démonstratif
ça dissuade des gens dans les dans la
rue c'est pas prouvé ça va pas être
prouvé d'un regard extérieur quand on a
suivi les révolutions arabes ça
ressemblait quand même à une politique
de maintien de l'ordre d'un pays du
tiers-monde parce que ça arrive une fois
dans la tête bon il était au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment deux fois
trois fois quatre fois quand on voit un
policier tirer marqué de la voix à voter
BIM ça devient problématique qu'on est
une politique de maintien de l'ordre ni
d'un pays du tiers-monde pour dissuader
les gens d'y arriver votre
interprétation du fait que il y a eu des
grenades de des fumigènes de la du Gacé
dans le cortège familial vous
n'interprétez pas ça comme une erreur
pour vous c'était voulu
oUI NON NON oui
je pense qu'il y a tout un ensemble de
signes
de communication ministérielle de la
préfète dans les jours précédents de la
manifestation qui avait pour but de
d'accroître la tension vous pensez que
ça a été fait dans le but d'accroître la
tension c'est ça
vous protégez pas un chantier vide comme
un fortin
ils avaient déployé quand même nombre
d'hélicoptères en amont ils avaient
prévenus que ça allait être violent
une grenade tous les quatre secondes
pendant toute une manifestation
je pense que c'est aussi important de
réancrer un peu le dans quel moment
est-ce que ça s'en crée c'était un
moment de contestation sociale hyper
forte à ce moment-là où il y avait
je pense encore une fois une une
matérialisation éclatante du dénigrement
de notre cher Président de la République
contre la démocratie contre le fait de
ne pas écouter les gens le fait de
outrepasser totalement la volonté des
gens plus que plus de trois quarts des
gens ne voulaient absolument pas de
cette réforme il y avait à ce moment-là
du coup les personnes qui à force de
descendre dans la rue et de ne pas être
entendus il y avait ça montait un petit
peu en tension il y avait même des
sondages qui montrait que la plus de la
majorité des personnes étaient ok et
même souhaitait que le niveau dans la
rue progresse et aille plus loin pour
justement j'ai commencé à se faire
entendre et je pense que là c'était
stratégique pour eux à ce moment là
parce que évidemment que les personnes
qui vont à Sainte Soline c'est aussi des
personnes qui sont dans la rue qui
étaient dans la rue la semaine d'avant
où il y avait plein de garde à vue
arbitraire etc
c'est les mêmes personnes en fait qui
est sur sur ces deux-là enfin qui était
donc voilà dans ces deux contestations
là et je pense que c'était vraiment
stratégique pour eux à ce moment-là
d'effrayer de de vraiment traumatiser
les gens pour faire en sorte que la
contestation cesse
vous ou tu parles de du fait qu'il y a
eu des blessés très graves dans le rond
des manifestants côté soulèvement de la
terre c'est très grave à quel point
c'est dans le commun il y a eu des
réparations il y a eu des enfancements
de mode crânienne ça ressemble à quoi
pour que les gens comprennent ce que
vous avez reçu
alors ça ressemble à deux personnes du
coup qui à la sortie de la manifestation
ont été dans le coma les secours n'ont
pas pu arriver sur place donc la Ligue
des droits de l'homme était sur place et
l'a testé plus tard dans un certain
nombre d'articles ça ressemble à 70
personnes qui ont fini avec
des séquelles fonctionnelles une jeune
fille de 19 ans mâchoire arrachée
voilà des éclats de grenades dans les
jambes etc plein de choses et en tout
200 personnes blessées sur le moment
après juste pour finir avec ce que vous
disiez avant je pense que à ce moment là
ce qui était voulu c'était calmer les
troupes parce que si vous voulez quand
vous êtes la préfète votre
interprétation interprétation c'est qu'à
ce moment là il voulait il voulait
calmer les troupes on était déjà venus à
Sainte-Souline on avait fait trois
cortèges comme des gros malins et on
avait réussi à s'introduire dans la
bassine vous avez humilié
nous revenons
c'est pas bien nous revenons à Sainte
Soline en mars quelques mois plus tard
Gérald Darmanin avait déjà dit qu'il
voulait nous dissoudre et là on est plus
6000 on est 30 000 bon petit
augmentation sympa 30 000 personnes
c'est pas 30 000 personnes qui vivent
sur une pétition en ligne qui jette de
la peinture sur un tableau sans vouloir
discréditer ce genre de choses c'est
30000 personnes qui font pour beaucoup
une journée de route qui viennent
s'installer dans la boue une boire
gileuse vous voyez en dans les dans les
Deux Sèvres il y a du vent camper on
fait 10 km de marche pour atteindre
pour atteindre une espèce de trou
d'accord donc ça veut dire que en
puissance on est beaucoup plus que 30000
parce que les gens qui ont accepté de
faire ça après leur semaine de travail
ça demande une certaine motivation je
peux finir mon développement parce que
sinon ça marche pas
il y a 30000 personnes qui viennent
parce que il y a des
infirmiers des infirmières des gens
qu'on appelle les médicaments
et donc déjà vous réussissez à vous
implanter donc sur un camp trouver en
loose D
qui va vous permettre derrière de
pouvoir aller jusqu'à la bassine ensuite
vous faites venir un convoi de tracteur
parce qu'elle est soulèvement de la
terre c'est il y a toujours des
tracteurs qui viennent manifester
administrativement
le convoi de tracteur et bien sûr bloqué
parce que la préfète ne veut pas non
plus que les tracteurs atteignent la
zone que déjà un certain nombre de
manifestants même sous soumis à tes
contrôles on t'atteint donc le convoi
est bloqué on se dit mince on va pas
réussir à faire venir les tracteurs et
là vous avez un blocage simultané d'une
ligne de train et d'une départementale
qui message à la préfète si vous ne
développez pas le convoi de tracteur on
reste bloqué ces deux endroits là vous
emmerdez les gens qui vont bosser et
vous emmerdez les gens qui vont prendre
le temps
non non c'était un soir les gens et le
blocage n'a pas dû n'a pas eu à être pas
du tout et vous avez les tracteurs qui
ont été qui ont été qui ont été
débloqués et qui ont pu atteindre la
cible donc au bout d'un moment la
préfète elle se dit commence
à en avoir marre auparavant vous aviez
eu effectivement des choses qui les
avaient alerté vous avez des soirées
publiques dans tout le pays sur le sujet
vous avez un certain d'annonces vous
sentez un certain nombre de composantes
que la manifestation est internationale
que la veille a eu des débats sur l'eau
avec des gens de tout un tas de pays
vous vous dites bon bah là il va falloir
leur montrer que ça va pas se passer
comme ça et du coup ils prévoient non on
cherche à avoir de l'impact et on a
réussi et on a réussi et on a réussi en
deux ans alors que les gens puissent
sortaient de du confinement qui était
complètement aseptisé on a réussi à en
deux ans à créer des mobilisations de
masse impactantes qui vont désarmer un
certain nombre d'infrastructures et qui
font qu'il y a un débat sur la gestion
de l'eau en France alors qu'avant il
était complètement tu et que et puis
prévoir que la question des usages
injustes de l'eau allait être posée il y
a deux trois ans il a fallu
la sécheresse et il a fallu les
soulèvements de la terre pour que ça
devienne un débat public ce sujet et
donc c'est un travail de pédagogie c'est
pas une avant-garde c'est un travail de
conscientisation de l'ensemble de la
population sur ou est-ce qu'on va sur
notre territoire dans un contexte de
dérèglement de la planète
les blessés qui a eu à Sainte Soline
est-ce que vous avez pris des nouvelles
des blessés qu'il y avait eu en face à
la police
ils annoncent toujours le même nombre de
blessés que chez nous
ils avaient en face non ça forme pas
c'est un corps de métier ils ont tous
ils ont ils ont des armures ils ont un
tas d'armes pour se défendre
personnellement je me suis pas renseigné
sur le nombre de blessés du côté des
policiers je suis désolé mais les deux
qui sont dans le coma comment ils se
portent
ils sont sortis très récemment du commun
ils ont des grosses séquelles
on leur souhaite beaucoup de courage
revenons à la perception de tout ça
avant j'aimerais quand même qu'on parle
du renseignement d'infiltration comment
vous percevez le fait que vous soyez
fliqué à gauche à droite parce que pour
le camp d'en face vous reposez vous
représentez une menace nécessitant une
dissolète une dissolution
Christophe a lancé le débat sur le futur
Marcel aussi sur qu'est-ce qui va se
passer plus tard l'écho anxiété les
médias propagent les cours anxiété
et vous aussi auprès de la population et
la seule réponse politique qui a c'est
vous prenez les forces de police dans la
tête quand vous essayez de montrer que
les projets sont pas viables à moyen et
long terme
comment vous percevez ça est-ce que vous
avez des enfants comptez faire des
enfants comment vous gérez la fonction
exponentielle de croissance des
populations
vous attendez à quoi juste sur sur la
fonction exponentielle de croissance des
populations il y a un historien de le
HES historien de l'économie stanzanie tu
le connais oui
Alexandre tanzani qui qui explicite que
dans les 1000 dernières années
l'augmentation de la de la population a
été de
x 24 alors que l'augmentation de notre
consommation a été de fois 400 donc on
sait très bien que le problème c'est
notre consommation et ce n'est pas du
tout la population
si on consomme tous moins on est qu'on
continue à
juste gagner les comment dire
mais il y a eu des il y a eu pas mal de
donc il y a des personnes dont c'est le
métier de travailler sur voilà les
projections de démographie et on n'est
pas du tout sur une trajectoire
exponentielle on est plutôt sur une
trajectoire qui devrait se qui devrait
se stabiliser alors c'est encore des
projections et il y a rien que
à l'échelle globale à l'échelle globale
après peut-être que c'est pas mais je
presse pas non plus peut-être le cœur du
débat mais mais en tout cas sur sur ce
que tu disais par rapport à l'écho
anxiété là où je te rejoins pas du tout
c'est quand tu dis que que les
soulèvements de la terre du coup
poussent à l'écho anxiété enfin en tout
cas moi personnellement vraiment le ma
rencontre avec les soulèvements de la
terre j'ai l'impression que que
justement au contraire c'est c'est ça
oui dans le sens où maintenant je fais
dans le sens où maintenant je m'implique
dans le sens où maintenant je rencontre
plein de gens qui sont hyper
intéressants plein de gens qui qui
s'impliquent énormément qui qui
consacrent enfin qui consacré énormément
de temps de leur vie à faire en sorte
que les choses aillent mieux qu'ils sont
en train de construire plein de choses
qui sont en train de construire l'après
ce que j'ai l'impression qu'avec avec
tout un peu l'imaginaire du de
l'effondrement en fait j'ai l'impression
que on est en train de dire c'est
horrible parce qu'on va pas réussir à
maintenir notre société actuelle sauf
qu'en fait moi je voilà sauf que moi je
trouve ça réjouissant de pas réussir à
maintenir notre société dans la forme
actuelle
voilà et que du coup il y a plein de
d'autres possibilités de sociétés qui
sont possibles de faire avec notamment
plus d'autonomie locale avec peut-être
que les personnes pourraient peut-être
plus décider c'est quoi les
infrastructures qu'il y a autour d'elle
et les choix sociétaux techniques sur
lesquels on les emmène je finis juste
mon raisonnement et du coup vraiment
j'ai l'impression que la plupart des
personnes que j'ai pu croiser par
exemple dans les 180 au comités locaux
des soulèvements de la terre je dis pas
tout te rencontrer mais mais
quelques-unes parce qu'il y a eu souvent
des intercommités où on s'est rencontrés
et pas au contraire non c'est que il y a
vraiment une joie de militer une joie de
d'intégrer des luttes locales de
découvrir qu'en fait c'est possible de
faire des choses maintenant tout de
suite et de pu être dans l'attente que
l'État prenne des décisions et d'être en
permanence déçu mais vas-y tu avais une
question oui bien sûr merci beaucoup
dans les gens que tu rencontres il y a
des gens qui réfléchissent à basculement
de société et alternative c'est ça
est-ce qu'ils ont modélisé ce
basculement de société dans un contexte
de guerre économique à l'échelle
mondiale
avec des gens de l'autre côté de la
frontière ou de l'autre côté du
continent qui ont pas du tout cette même
façon de penser de on va se mettre une
petite fleur dans les cheveux et on va
tous faire des bisous et tout va bien se
passer la transition ça va passer soft
soft stop super cool est-ce que des tas
rencontré des gens qui modélisent le
fait que la France est peut-être
l'Europe
bascule et n'emmène pas le monde entier
avec elle dans ce basculement est-ce
qu'ils ont modélisé le fait que
peut-être qu'on allait livrer la France
et l'Europe à se faire dépecer par les
gens qui vont pas du tout accepter la
synchronicité de se basculement de
société de ce changement de société
est-ce que peut-être que ces gens ont
anticipé le fait que l'État redoute ça
par tous les moyens et cherche à vous
neutraliser par tous les moyens parce
que ils se disent ah cette bande de
hippies mais cette bande de hippie
ils nous font prendre des risques parce
qu'ils ne comprennent pas ou ils n'ont
pas modélisé les facteurs de guerre
économique avec des gens ou des états
des prédateurs et le capitalisme à côté
c'est des gentils petits bisounours donc
est-ce que tu as rencontré ce type de
personne qui modélise ce changement se
basculement de société ou on essaye de
faire mieux avec moi
avec des méchants tout autour
là dessus je pense par exemple
à Jérôme Bachet qui a écrit sur
justement ce basculement qui a beaucoup
écrit dessus et où lui il a il est allé
au Chapas ou du coup auprès des apathes
qui sont en train de développer une
autonomie qui est qui est réelle qui
dure depuis plus de 30 ans maintenant et
sur une sur un sur une sur à l'échelle
de voilà d'une zone qui correspond à la
Belgique donc un pays et où il y a
vraiment des choses concrètes qui sont
faites et ils doivent effectivement
lutter contre de narcotrafiquants contre
des ministres de l'armée etc donc en
tout cas dans le sens de est-ce que
cette vision là de de plus d'autonomie
de de choses plus ancrées avec des
personnes qui assurent plus leur
subsistance et sont plus dans ce
capitalisme marchand etc il y a déjà des
gens qui le mettent en place dans des
territoires qui sont éminemment
conflictuels et est-ce que j'ai donc oui
je pense avoir croisé des personnes qui
qui
mon compte ces réflexions là ensuite
j'ai l'impression que en tout cas que du
côté des soulèvements de la terre là
comme comme Adèle l'a rappelé la
préoccupation première qui nous anime
c'est vraiment le enfin l'eau la
nourriture le les choses basiques quoi
sont lesquelles on ne peut pas imaginer
la suite et que du coup bah par exemple
est-ce que c'est pertinent les bassines
en condition de guerre ou pas dans tous
les cas si elles peuvent pas être
remplies je pense qu'elles sont pas
pertinentes quoi mais si je peux
permettre
détour historiques
à la fin du XVIIIe siècle les quelques
philosophes des Lumières qui étaient
contre l'esclavage d'ailleurs c'était
pas tous
c'était des hippies utopistes pour les
gens sérieux
concrètement le commerce extérieur de la
France et de l'Angleterre à cette époque
là dépendait aux deux tiers du commerce
triangulaire et des relations avec les
Antilles
et donc ça paraissait irréalisable de
sortir du modèle esclavagiste pourtant
trois quarts de siècles plus tard on en
est sorti donc il y a des choses qui
peuvent paraître extrêmement utopiques
qui en fait à force de se bagarrer
d'être droit dans ses bottes sur des
questions de justice de droit humain de
dignité de la personne on doit les
défendre même si on est minoritaire mais
si on est taxé de doux utopiste c'est
vrai que les anti-esclavagistes du 19e
siècle ils avaient pas prévu que la
Chine allait avoir des millions de
travailleuses et travailleurs au début
du 20e 21e siècle esclavagisé et que
donc j'imagine que derrière ta question
est un petit peu ça qu'est-ce qui va se
passer si on se développe moins vite et
que la Chine nous colonise et que ça
en fait je suis plus je répondrai comme
ça je suis pas du tout un prospectiviste
un petit peu le même argument que les
arguments anti-esclavagistes de la fin
du XVIIIe siècle c'est-à-dire c'est une
question de principe c'est une question
de ce qu'on pense de la dignité humaine
et de ce que vaut la vie humaine il y a
même un c'était Clémenceau au Parlement
à la vers les années 1880 face à Jules
Ferry il dit je sais plus plutôt ne pas
se développer que d'avoir des colonies
c'est que peut-être à un moment des gens
en Russie vont se révolter contre le
modèle oppressif qui vive des gens en
Chine on se révoltait et donc voilà de
partir de la dignité du présent en
espérant que ça va faire tâche d'huile
c'est typiquement un pari de la gauche
un pari du progressisme Gilles Deleuze
disait être de gauche c'est faire le
pari que le peuple pense vous êtes de
gauche ici ben en tout cas c'est un
projet émancipateur c'est faire le pari
que les Chinois les Russes
les Birmans ils ont la même aspiration à
la liberté à l'autonomie à l'égalité que
nous et que ces choses là peuvent faire
tâches d'huile et qu'on les peuples
voilà c'est un vieux rêve Jaurès lavait
il a perdu pourquoi pas il s'est fait
assassiné en 1914 mais je pense qu'on
peut encore le porter pourquoi il y a
pas la droite
est-ce que dans les soulèvements feux
les soulèvements de la terre dit soit
administrativement parlant est-ce qu'il
y a des gens de droite alors je parle
pas de la droite dur dur
genre des gens
de droite genre bouddhiste un truc qui
ressemble quoi il y a des gens comme ça
chez vous ou vous êtes tous en mode on
est de gauche on est de gauche vous
savez si c'est difficile
c'est difficile de répondre à votre
question sur la modélisation parce
qu'elle est soulèvement de la terre tu
pars c'est un mouvement qui part des
territoires et notamment en partie des
métiers qui sont cassés sur les
territoires le métier d'agriculteur moi
je peux parler du métier de Bûcheron
vous voulez aujourd'hui il y a un
certain nombre de projets qui est de
projets subventionnés par exemple les
abatteuses en France elles sont
subventionnées
qui abattent les arbres en forêt il est
super robots une
foresterie avec de moins en moins de
forestiers et de bûcherons et une
agriculture avec de moins en moins
d'agriculteurs et d'agriculture
c'est pas le sujet
je suis désolé
on part on part des territoires dans les
territoires par exemple je suis dans le
Massif central le vote est fan il est
très très développé et je côtoie un
grand nombre de gens qui je pense vote
est fan et pourtant matériellement dans
la vie je sais pas quoi ce qui va être
mais je me doute quoi on partage un
certain nombre de coups de main on
partage un certain nombre de conditions
vous voyez le fait de ne pas être
reconnu le fait qu'on s'abote en fait
des des métiers parce qu'on s'abote les
conditions de possibilités de ces
métiers
donc
je sais pas s'il y a des gens de droite
dans les soulèvements de la terre par
exemple dans les gilets jaunes c'était
un peu trouble cette histoire et je
pense que les gestes qui sont réalisés
par les soulèvements de la terre font
beaucoup plus la sympathie de tout un
tas de gens qui sont mobilisés dans les
gilets jaunes que d'autres mouvements
écolos avec une bonne petite identité
bien consciente donc aujourd'hui
moi ce qui me porte dans ce mouvement et
je pense l'endroit où il a été très
juste c'est l'endroit de la zone de
basculement possible par exemple une
chose qui qui moi m'est restée et que je
le trouvais très intéressante que les
médias n'ont bien sûr pas eu trop
relevés c'est que la première
manifestation qui a été faite à Sainte
Soline le camp de base s'est installé
chez un ex-firigan chez un mec qui est
intervenu qui a dit moi j'accueille les
gens ici le gars il avait changé de
position il avait compris il avait
compris que ça allait pas marcher ces
trucs là donc
je pense que c'est un mouvement
fondamentalement
qui qui porte des valeurs de gauche au
sens par exemple une des valeurs qui est
portée par le mouvement et qui est peu
mise en avant mais au fond qui est très
importante c'est que aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas d'agriculture dans ce pays sans
des personnes
issues de l'immigration avec ou sans
papiers qui ramasse les légumes on l'a
vu pendant le covid s'en est rendu
compte et les fruits d'accord que ces
gens là ils aient des conditions de
travail déplorables je pense que les
soulèvements de la terre la ligne c'est
que ce n'est pas possible et que un
projet social bien sûr
par les pesticides c'est des camions qui
amènent du sable c'est un usage de l'eau
inconsidérée qui essaient comme une
Chevrolière qui essaye de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse préempter la terre
d'installer des maraîchers etc voilà
donc il y a un salon de mairie de droite
qui ont conscience que il y a un
processus proliférant
d'industrialisation dans tous les
studières de la Loire qui a un danger
pour la qualité de vie des habitants et
qu'on soit de droite ou de gauche dans
ces cas-là le combat est commun
pas spécialement mais juste peut-être
ajouter le fait que que ce qui est ce
que je trouve puissant chez les
soulèvements de la terre c'est qu'on se
retrouve pour faire une action ensemble
on se retrouve pas pour discuter et pour
se mettre d'accord sur comment dire sur
enfin par exemple dans les comités
locaux
et ben ce qui ce qui est assez fort
c'est que les gens en fait ont
conscience que si on s'y réunit et que
on discute pendant 1000 ans sur on fait
une charte on se met d'accord sur faut
qu'on soit tous ensemble d'accord sur
c'est quoi notre politique c'est quoi
notre etc on sait qu'on va pas agir
alors que là justement j'ai l'impression
que il y a un dépassement de ça il y a
un dépassement de faut qu'on soit
d'accord politiquement avant d'agir
ensemble et c'est non là en fait on peut
plus payer le luxe vis-à-vis de la
situation de d'abord réfléchir faire des
réunions se mettre d'accord sur vraiment
plein de choses très particulières etc
avant d'agir collectivement ensemble
j'ai une question purement
technique il faut combien de
permaculture de permaculteur pour
nourrir Paris
il faut quelle surface
il y a une dizaine d'années et qui
montrait que la grue écologie peut
nourrir le monde
mais est-ce que la permaculture c'est ce
qu'on défend non je pose une question
est-ce que la permaculture est-ce que
arrêter d'artificialiser les seuls
arrêtez de faire des immenses
boutiques de maraîchage ou d'entreprises
de maraîchage ou des immenses terrains
céréaliers est-ce que l'agriculture
locale l'agriculture de du coin est
capable de nourrir la densité parisienne
à l'heure actuelle ou la densité de
l'Île-de-France oUI NON NON oui c'est
une question qui me passe par la tête je
pense que oui
il y a eu des travaux depuis le 19e
siècle de Sabine barde sur
l'approvisionnement de Paris en bois et
en ressources agricoles et on voit que
ça va chercher le bois jusqu'au Morvan
et l'agriculture dans tout le bassin
parisien le Charolais pour la viande et
que aujourd'hui dans on est dans une
situation en Île-de-France il y a plus
d'abattoirs c'est à dire il y a plus
d'élevage il y a une spécialisation
exclusive dans les grandes cultures qui
sont exportées pour moitié pour de
l'élevage qui se fait ailleurs et donc
effectivement dans une logique de
relocalisation il faut remettre de
l'élevage il faut refaire du fumier et
il faut installer là où il y a des
fermes de 500 hectares en pure céréales
on peut installer 10 maraîchers sur deux
hectares ça enlève pas beaucoup à la
grande ferme céréalière au moment où
elle se transmet et on approvisionne
Paris comme ça
de cette année pour la France en termes
d'agriculture de bouffe c'est combien
ces 5 milliards c'est ça je sais plus le
problème c'est que on a fait le choix
depuis un centre de décennie d'exporter
des céréales valeur ajoutée très faible
et d'importer des produits à forte
valeur ajoutée les fruits et légumes qui
peuvent venir des pays du Sud de la
viande qui est nourrit au soja
lointaine des produits transformés qui
sont pas toujours fabriqués en France et
donc il y a aussi disons une erreur en
termes de si on cherche non pas
uniquement en volume mais en qualité
alimentaire en valeur ajoutée on peut
largement faire d'autres choix et il y a
des calculs qui ont été faits à partir
de d'un mois je suis désolé un modèle
d'agroécologie et de faire de ma culture
dans une ferme en Normandie le bec est
loin qui montre qu'on dégage 50000 euros
à l'hectare sur ce modèle de petites
fermes intensives en travail alors que
sur la même terre c'est une terre
céréalière de l'Eure-et-Loir on dégage
3000 euros avec subventions européenne
et donc d'un point de vue de la
rationalité économique on peut faire
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on fait
pourquoi vous avez été dissout
bande de terroristes
pourquoi vous avez été dissous comment
ça s'est passé administrativement
parlant il y a eu des perquisitions
comment ça s'est passé alors la séquence
de la dissolution déjà est-ce que T2
acolytes sont d'accord pour que ce soit
toi qui répondent très bien
la séquence de la dissolution ça a
commencé par un la première note qui
nous est parvenue c'était dans un
article du Parisien en décembre après
une action qui n'avait pas été organisée
par les soulèvements de la terre mais
qui avait été extrêmement efficace
action contre une usine Lafarge à
Bouc-Bel-Air revendiquer par une entité
inconnue
et
cette action a été
citée dans cet article du Parisien et
derrière associé au soulèvement de la
terre qui avait relayé l'action donc
c'est 4 millions d'euros Ros de dégâts
en un quart d'heure n'a jamais vu une
action aussi peu violente avec autant de
dégâts
puisqu'il ne s'est rien passé de plus
que que
qu'un certain nombre de dégradations
et ensuite vous avez un article donc
dans Le Parisien qui dit qui dit que
Gérald Darmanin a bien envie de
dissoudre
quelques mois se passent réaction à cet
article il y a une tribune qui qui est
publiée dans le monde avec plus de 3000
signatures de plein de personnalités
publiques on obtient 3000 signatures en
24 heures je crois c'est moi ensuite
vous avez sans Soline et
là Gérald Darmanin du coup nous accuse
de déco terroristes et dit je veux
dissoudre pendant une semaine la presse
les différentes radios
les soulèvements sont appelés de de
partout il y a une aura médiatique comme
ça très forte et la dissolution ne vient
pas donc de conseils des ministres en
conseil des ministres ou c'est censé
être discuter ça n'est pas discuté
pourquoi à ce moment-là parce que à
partir de cette menace de dissolution
vous avez eu des rassemblements dans
énormément de villes en France vous avez
eu la création de 170 comités locaux
vous avez eu des tribunes qui ont été
écrites qui ont rassemblé un grand
nombre de signatures un meeting sur
Paris avec un grand nombre de
personnalités justement d'aller chercher
des gens de qui représentaient des
collectifs mais aussi des gens qui
étaient dans des instances scientifiques
c'était un peu une guerre médiatique à
ce moment là enfin une bataille en tout
cas
et puis vous avez une espèce d'adhésion
en ligne possible qui vous fait
appartenir au mouvement aujourd'hui à
peu près 150 000 signatures sans sous
non rien
donc hashtag je suis les soulèvements de
la terre
face à cette réaction je pense qui est
un peu inattendue pour le gouvernement
il se disent on n'a pas tout à fait les
moyens de dissoudre en plus ils
identifient mal qui fait partie du
mouvement qui n'en fait pas partie étant
donné qu'il y a énormément de gens qui a
plein de syndicats qui a des
organisations de jeunes pour le climat
qui a un grand nombre de collectifs
locaux ils se disent mais c'est c'est
qui ces gens-là finalement comment on
les dissout donc ils identifient
facilement un ou deux porte-parole et il
nous donne un espèce de une espèce de
notification
ils vont la donner à des gens ils vont à
la date de notre reine des Landes c'est
plus facile ce qu'ils ont vu des gens
parler qui était peut-être des gens qui
habitaient là-bas etc donc
ils ont ils ont fait quoi donc ils vont
donner ils vont donner ce papier et
après
il y a une équipe qui qui travaille avec
des avocats sur les soulèvements de la
terre ok son pays commence c'est gratuit
c'est bénévoles il y a plein de dons qui
sont faits au soulèvement de la Terre
depuis que le mouvement
quand même
je te rassure que les banquiers
t'inquiète pas c'est open bar donc c'est
pas ce qui est important
ensuite du côté du côté en face tu es
perçu comment est-ce que c'est une
organisation qui est pyramidale non il y
a de l'argent qui est réparti dans tout
un tas d'associations en France des
associations
de la répression c'est toute une équipe
assez composite qui travaille avec des
avocats sur la défense du mouvement et
précisément dans la procédure de
dissolution
qui défend le mouvement c'est ça
c'est une équipe qui
fait partie du mouvement à chaque fois
que vous faites quelque chose pour le
moment vous faites partie du mouvement
vous voyez c'est c'est flou le la
membrane qui définit l'intérieur à
l'extérieur de ce mouvement
est-ce que je peux je peux finir ensuite
on pourra présenter comment marche
comment comment ça marche les interluent
comment se décide des actions comment ça
c'est structuré depuis deux années on
peut faire ça oui bien sûr
donc le vous avez une contestation de de
cette première notification qui est
réalisée où on nous accuse dans un
certain nombre de choses d'avoir fait
des actions d'avoir appelé un certain
nombre de choses qui en fait jusque là
son public
et puis
après ah oui vous avez surtout ce qui a
été fort à ce moment-là à mon sens c'est
que du coup la dissolution n'a pas lieu
et le mouvement avec toutes ces
organisations composites qui ne sont
pourtant pas des des grands méchants
maintiennent les actions qui sont
prévues dans la fin de la saison donc
une manifestation à tout proche de
Toulouse qui réunit plus de 8000
personnes une manifestation contre le
lion Turin et une manifestation à
saint-colombe et à la fin de l'année
sous les les ordres de la FNSEA enfin
sous la pression de la FNSEA
l'article s'appelle comment la FNSEA a
eu la peau de soulèvement de la terre il
y a une enquête qui a été faite qui
n'est pas contente par Gaspard d'alansk
et un journaliste reporter qui du coup
se sent attaqué puisque la Fédération
des maraîchers nantait a été ciblée sur
cette action là
ce sont attaqué donc demande la
dissolutions
ils ont été ciblés par un certain nombre
d'actions donc donc
l'eau qui l'eau qui permettait
l'irrigation a été coupée il y a eu
l'arrachage de muguet et la plantation
d'un semis de sarrasin bio vous avez
fermé le robinet le robinet a été fermé
il a pas été arraché
si si il y a eu du
pourquoi arracher est-ce que je peux
finir mon développement
donc la expérience de cet industriels
avec des nouveaux pesticides qui posent
des problèmes et donc cet essai là a été
aussi quelque peu dégradé en échange
vous semez du sarrasin pour montrer que
il y a d'autres types de culture que le
bocage a été éradiqué dans cette zone
que toute la zone est en sablée que
aujourd'hui c'est en 2006 il y avait 88%
de la match française qui était produite
en leur Atlantique donc on désertifie
les alentours de Nantes
juste on
implante enfin on apporte du sable en
grande quantité juste pour robotiser
plus facilement
donc suite à cette action là qui ne
plaît pas à la FNA ils disent on va s'en
on va y aller nous-mêmes si vous les
dissolvez pas et on va y aller nous-même
de la part
on va aller on va aller on va on va
aller en face d'eux on va on va empêcher
ses actions si le gouvernement
ne met pas les moyens en oeuvre pour que
ces actions soient empêchées moi c'est
comme ça que je comprends c'est à la
tête de la Fnac du président de la FNSEA
qui par ailleurs on pourra en reparler a
fait tout un tas d'actions de
dégradation énorme dans son histoire et
à obtenu les choses qu'elle voulait
ainsi donc vous voyez il y a deux fois
de mesures
qui a eu deux fois ses pneus dévissés
donc là c'est pas une violence c'est une
violence sur les personnes c'est pas
juste une pompe arrachée on est vraiment
dans un autre modèle d'action qui est
qualifié de SEM par le journaliste du
Monde qui a travaillé là-dessus c'est un
livre qui s'appelle silence dans les
champs de Nicolas Legendre et c'est
vraiment intéressé au pouvoir de la
FNSEA et derrière de l'agro industrie
dans cette région et qui fait qu'il est
très difficile d'être en désaccord
d'être un lanceuse d'alerte d'être une
journaliste qui travaille sur les algues
vertes voilà ces personnes là sont
exposées à des violences sur leur
intégrité
physiquement de la terre c'est en
réponse au dégradation c'est en réponse
à quoi
c'était en réponse à un documentaire
qu'elle avait fait sur quoi
industrie en Bretagne il y a un
documentaire qui était passé sur France
Télévisions par ailleurs elle écrit dans
un journal
et elle étudie des questions disons de
lanceur d'alerte qui se de gens qui
travaillent ou qui sont ouvriers dans
des coopératives qui manipulent des
produits
alors elle a demandé une protection
policière la police lui a dit et il en
est pas question
je pense qu'elle a porté plainte et qui
doit y avoir une enquête par contre
donc on finit sur ce qui s'est passé
pour la deuxième fois sur son domicile
c'est à dire il y a une récidive dans
cette affaire de pneus de
roues dévissée
très bien
il faut le dresser à refuser la pas ils
ont empoisonné son chien également
pas longtemps mais ça démarre vite
désolé pour la boutade
juin si je me trompe pas pour de la Fête
de la Musique super et fallait pas faire
des fêtes de pique-nique aussi je
déteste
c'est pour ça que je travaille avec une
tronçonneuse d'ailleurs et je préfère la
hache
et
vous avez
ce qui est bien plus
bien plus menaçant peut-être que la
dissolution qui n'a fait finalement pour
l'instant que renforcer l'aura du
mouvement et
son ça ça disparité sur le sur le
territoire vous avez deux vagues
d'arrestation qui ont eu lieu début juin
et le 20 juin et la veille de la
dissolution comme par hasard sur
l'affaire de Bouc-Bel-Air donc une
affaire
qui est mené par la juge d'Aix en
Provence qui est censé vous comprenez
être indépendante elle enquête sur quoi
sur les déclarations
où il y a 200 personnes qui se sont
introduits dans une usine Lafarge et qui
ont fait un certain nombre de
dégradations c'est son boulot elle fait
son boulot mais pourquoi il y a une
vague d'arrestation la veille de la
dissolution une vague d'arrestation qui
comprend les personnes calendrier des
personnes des soulèvement de la terre
dont des personnes qui ont été très
exposées médiatiquement alors au nom du
participe
je n'en sais rien moi enfin qui c'était
pas c'était pas une action des
soulèvements de la terre
donc à ce moment là nous on a vraiment
l'impression que la juge d'Aix et une
sorte de marionnette du ministère de
l'Intérieur qu'elle a été utilisée
un certain nombre de perquisition
qui sont faites qui sont faites la
veille
qui sont faites la veille de la
dissolution avec un certain nombre de
personnes qui du coup vont être
empêché de se défendre ou de
d'intervenir dans les médias le jour de
la dissolution quand vous savez par des
contacts avec des avocats que la juge
d'Aix-en-Provence
est très déstabilisé par le fait d'avoir
à gérer autant d'arrestations et autant
de garde à vue d'un coup ce jour-là fait
son boulot vous vous dites justification
salaire vous vous dites qu'il y a une
sorte de collusion entre un calendrier
politique et une affaire qui est censée
être indépendante ensuite cette affaire
ce qui est ressenti étonnant on pourra
revenir là-dessus
sur l'affaire antiterroriste
est en charge des procédures c'est à
dire que elle sous-traitent un dossier
qui n'est pas
de qui n'est pas du régime de
l'anti-terroriste
elle sous traite parce que on n'est pas
dire que c'est une affaire l'affaire de
Bouc-Bel-Air pour l'instant est une
affaire criminelle donc c'est à dire que
ce n'est pas du ce n'est pas des
compétences de de l'entité terrorisme et
vous avez
parce que ce n'est pas ce régime là
l'antitorisme la sous-direction
antiterroriste elle travaille de manière
privilégiée avec la DGSI c'est sûr de
toi oui je suis sûr de ce que je dis
aujourd'hui cette affaire là qui n'est
pas du ressort de l'antitorisme ne
devrait pas enfin en tout cas c'est
nouveau que la date face ce travail là
que les gens sont emmenés en garde à vue
de 96 heures à Levallois-Perret alors
que cette affaire n'est pas du ressort
de l'entité
je pense que c'est pas de l'entité mais
c'est peut-être que n'est pas l'enquête
n'est pas une enquête sur avec des chefs
d'incubation qui concernent le
terrorisme
c'est de l'ordre criminel et d'ailleurs
c'est de l'ordre criminel parce qu'il y
a eu des incendies de machines sinon ça
le serait pas Marcel tu tu vas demander
compléter
peut-être compléter aussi qu'il y avait
des personnes enfin que dans ces deux
vagues d'arrestation qui a eu il y avait
des personnes également qui étaient
inculpées pour participation à Sainte
Soline mise en examen pour pour
participation à la manifestation de
sainte Soline toujours les mêmes et
enfin je pense quelque chose qui peut
être révélateur de à quel point c'était
politique en fait ces arrestations c'est
notamment l'arrestation de Félix blanc
qui était un militant de Europe Écologie
Les Verts qui lui s'est sûr et certain
qu'il y était pas je dis pas que les
autres il était ils ont enfin mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que lui il y a
des je crois des photos ou en tout cas
enfin il était ce jour-là avec vin de
ses amis en train de fêter Noël
donc on se dit a priori ok ils avaient
quels éléments et alors a priori dans le
dossier les éléments qu'ils avaient
c'est ah bah il est venu une fois sur
une lutte écologiste contre la
bétonisation de certaines terres et il y
a une photo où on dirait lui c'est quand
même léger quoi pour arrêter une
personne je trouve que c'est léger oh je
trouve personnellement
pas ma connaissance je sais pas
je sais pas j'ai pas la fête de Noël ont
été mis sur écoute pour savoir s'il
était là j'ai pas du tout connaissance
du dossier j'ai juste connaissance de ce
qu'a dit marine tondeuillier sur sur ce
cas précis et où du coup je pense que ça
enfin ça montre quand même le peu
d'éléments peut-être sur lequel il se
base pour arrêter les gens quoi parce
que enfin de ce que décrit du coup cette
personne qui a été arrêtée que je
rappelle a été arrêté à 6h du matin
devant sa femme son enfant de 5 ans par
des personnes qui enfin c'est quand même
assez impressionnant quoi qui arrive qui
ont des armes qui sont masquées qui
voilà il y a quand même enfin c'est
impressionnant quoi et donc du coup
ouais enfin ça montre quand même le je
pense à quel point c'était politique
d'avoir besoin d'arrêter plein de gens
la veille de la dissolution et le peu
d'éléments sur lequel ils avaient
c'est la veille du coup cette veille de
dissolution vous avez à la fois des
arrestations concernant le dossier de
l'organisation de la manifestation de
sainte Soline et à la fois des
arrestations qui sont liées à cette
enquête propre à Bouc-Bel-Air c'est là
que je vous dis que la juge elle a été
mise dans une situation particulière
c'est qu'elle elle se retrouve
prise en étau comme ça entre une affaire
qui ne la concerne pas quelque part
l'organisation de la manifestation de
sainte Soline qui est une affaire à part
qui ou une semaine après vous aurez
encore cette huit personnes
qui sont des représentations des
représentants syndicaux etc qui vont
passer une journée en garde à vue pour
l'organisation de cette manifestation
donc vous avez des arrestations qui
concernent les deux dossiers ensemble la
veille de la dissolution donc elle
voyait c'est pour ça que elle est voilà
c'est pour ça qu'elle est inconfortable
c'est qu'elle a traité dans un moment où
les feux des projecteurs sont sont si
blessure elle elle n'a pas le temps de
mener son enquête
c'est vous voyez les intuitions elles ne
sont elles ne viennent pas non plus de
connues
c'est des mots qui ont été soufflés par
les avocats des solvants de la terre
c'est pas la juge
alors si on regarde évidemment tu en
veux pas savoir ce qui se passe dans la
tête et dans les services qui nous
surveillent et qui nous répriment mais
dans entre 1920
documentaire sur Blast qui montre que
suite aux attentats de novembre 2015 la
première application de mesure
antiterroriste et appliquée aux
militants écolo qui ont été interdits de
manifestations contre la Coop
et que depuis 2015 on a un processus
d'assimilation croissante par le
gouvernement des activités écologiques a
du terrorisme si on regarde aussi un
petit peu sur un peu plus long terme
entre 4 raisons
que il y a des machins qui sont détruits
c'est pas un peu donner le bâton pour se
faire battre ce sont des dégâts
matériels
ça relève pas de la question du
terrorisme dont les lois elles ont été
faites face aux terrorisme islamistes
s'éloie là enfin on est différentes
formes
le terrorisme économique ils veulent pas
trop s'y intéresser mais
contre Lafarge qui finance des champs
Syrie
qui a été condamné aux États-Unis pour
avoir soutenu daesh
en examen en France pour complicité de
crime contre l'humanité ça a été terminé
aux États-Unis c'est réglé mais aux
États-Unis
et si on regarde les dissolutions
d'associations entre 4h10 et 2010 en 20
ans il y en a eu 6
si on regarde entre 2020 et aujourd'hui
il y en a eu 18 associations qui ont été
dissoutes certes ça va 18 fois plus vite
est-ce que aujourd'hui en 2023 on est
dans une France 18 fois plus menacée par
des activités terroristes dans les
années 90 il y a comme eu les
enlèvements de PDG dans les années 80
par des groupes d'extrême gauche il y a
quand même eu les attentats de
1995 est-ce que vraiment vous croyez que
oui c'était dans le métro là ouais ou
dans le est-ce que vous croyez vraiment
qu'on vit dans une France qui est 20
fois plus dangereuse que dans les années
90 est-ce que
c'est pas un nouveau cadre de gestion
des contestations qui est en train
d'apparaître et qui est en train de
criminaliser tous des accords avec les
logiques de nos gouvernants je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable tu m'autorise
vous motorisez
je me mets à la place de l'État
je vois des beatnik
Monnier
ma politique économique
alors que nous sommes en temps de guerre
que nous sommes en instabilité sur les
marchés internationaux
et les pique-niques c'est le gros
caillou dans ma chaussure et en plus de
ça il me laisse l'opportunité de les
caractériser comme terroristes parce
qu'ils font des dégradations violentes
il balance des cocktails monoto sur les
flics ils balancent des des billes
d'acier sur les flics bon
c'est pas logique un petit peu vous êtes
le caillou dans la dans le déploiement
de la politique de l'État
on peut plus vous parler
vous devenez vous devenez nombreux quand
même vous avez des capacités maintenant
vous pouvez fédérer des dizaines de
milliers de personnes en un claquement
de doigts
vous m'embêtez j'ai déjà eu les gilets
jaunes le covid la réforme des retraites
la guerre avec les Russes
la sécheresse les inondations et là les
pique-niques non mais vous cherchez
quand même
d'abord et soulèvement de la terre c'est
50% hippies 50% punk il faut le mélange
des deux blagues
la question c'est il y aura quoi après
mais non mais il faut vous avez changé
les sous-vêtements
de l'État et quel état enfin un état qui
a accompagné depuis 50 ans le tournant
néolibéral où la redistribution de la
valeur ajoutée va de plus en plus dans
le sens du capitalisme et des
actionnaires qui habitent à des milliers
de kilomètres de chez nous plutôt que
vers le les personnes qui travaillent
est-ce que enfin je vois pas l'intérêt
de se mettre à la place de cet état là
pour nous juger je pense qu'il y a des
endroits plus légitimes pour juger de la
légitimité de nos actions
Marcel non moi ce qui m'a interpellé
dans ta question c'est le fait d'avoir
dit on ne peut pas discuter
à la place de etc bien sûr bien sûr sauf
qu'en fait je pense que ceux qui se
disent on ne peut plus discuter en fait
c'est à la fois les personnes
dépendlieues qui se révoltent
actuellement c'est à la fois les gilets
jaunes c'est à la fois les soulèvements
de la terre administrativement dissous
c'est citoyens de la convention
citoyenne qui ont été piétinés oui c'est
fin c'est du coup c'est ces personnes là
qui disent on peut pas discuter il me
semble qu'il y avait une étude de
sociologie qui s'intéressait justement
au lutte territorial et qui montrait
bien qu'en fait le moment où les
modalités d'action commençaient à être
plus conséquente c'était justement quand
les personnes sentent que il n'y a pas
de débat possible et que la démocratie
que le le fait de la possibilité de
discussion d'échanges de se mettre
collectivement d'accord sur notre
trajectoire sociotechnique qu'on sait en
fait n'est pas écouté et c'est vraiment
ce qui se passe c'est vraiment ce qui se
passe en ce moment
les propositions politiques face à des
règlements climatiques face à la gestion
de l'eau face à la production de
particules avec les chaudières les pots
d'échappement les platines de disques
des freins disques et tout ce bordel et
ben moi j'ai l'impression vraiment que
on va comment dire dans le sens opposé
c'est à dire que les soulèvements de la
terre on s'attache à les soulèvements de
la terre administrativement dissous on
s'attache à de la des infrastructures
ces infrastructures c'est elle qui guide
en fait le justement la trajectoire
sociotechnique sur laquelle on va être
s'engagé pendant plusieurs années d'où
l'importance cruciale justement de les
empêcher de proliférer donc notamment on
peut revenir sur les méga bassines sur
les projets autoroutiers aussi sur
lesquels il y a eu beaucoup de d'actions
notamment lors de cette saison
et que et que et que du coup
et que du coup c'est
comment dire je crois que je suis en
train de me perdre désolé
en juillet 2022 par le Conseil d'État à
10 millions d'euros d'astreinte par
semestre pour inaction sur la pollution
atmosphérique ça c'est plutôt les oui
non mais évidemment c'est pas assez en
février 2023 suite à l'action l'affaire
du siècle des quatre ONG le tribunal
administratif de Paris a conseillé avec
l'État était responsable du non-respect
de ses engagements pris à la COP 21 dans
l'accord de Paris il va fixer des
astreintes à l'automne donc on attend ça
il y a une autre plainte de la ville de
Grande-Synthe pour une action climatique
qui a condamné l'état donc on est un
stade où on peut même plus parler
d'inction climatique en fait ça serait
trop gentil on est un stade où on a un
état qui est délinquant par rapport à
ses propres engagements et c'est la
police la justice qui le dit on est un
stade de contraction climatique on a un
pouvoir exécutif qui activement fait
tout ce qu'il faut pour que nous ne
bifurions pas pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
transition il y a des beaux discours
non c'est pas l'impression
je travaille sur ce conseil et ce qu'on
dit du réchauffement climatique depuis
les années 60 et j'ai notamment étudié
un moment clé du milieu des années 80 au
milieu des années 90 où l'alerte
climatique devient assez forte ou le
GIEC est créé en 88 donc le Groupe
intergouvernemental d'études du
changement climatique il rend son
premier rapport en 1990 qu'est-ce qu'il
y a dans son premier rapport il y a nous
allons nous prendre plus 0,3 degrés par
décennie dans les prochaines décennies
avec une incertitude de 0,1 à 0,5
ce qui correspond au réchauffement qu'on
a pris et qui se qui se profile et ils
disent nous en sommes certains dans le
dos de partie du rapport il y a d'autres
choses dont ils sont moins incertains
par exemple est-ce que la température de
1990 est déjà causée par l'action
humaine à ce moment-là on en est pas sûr
en 90 par contre l'idée qu'on va vers un
réchauffement de temps par décennies et
déjà affirmé dans ce rapport on est deux
ans avant la négociation de l'accord la
convention 4 sur le changement
climatique qui adoptait à Rio en 92 et
pendant ces deux années
aussi bien les lobbies industriels
Lafarge notamment
je l'ai publié le PDG de Lafarge faisait
partie d'une commission aux plantes qui
a dit on n'a pas besoin des contacts au
moment où la Commission européenne
mettait sur la table un projet d'écotax
Strauss-Kahn en tant que ministre va
bloquer ce projet d'écotaxe elle fait
total dans une coalition internationale
dans laquelle il y a ecson à travers
la chance
d'Elf et total il y a des anciens de la
direction environnement qui ont parlé
c'est pas des repentis mais ils ont été
assez transparents et notamment l'un
d'eux qui était le directeur
environnement d'elfe depuis 1983 et qui
est resté 20 ans donc il est il était
ensuite dans la période totale jusqu'en
2002 2003
qui me disait en 88 on savait qu'il y
avait la proposition d'une écotaxe
et il ne l'a pas démenti derrière donc
c'est
on savait que à une conférence des
Nations unies à Toronto il y avait une
déclaration qui disait il faut faire
moins 20% des missions globales entre 90
et 2005 et ces deux choses là nous ne
voulions pas que ça soit dans la
convention climat qui a adoptait à Rio
donc activement ils ont fait du lobbying
et du
climatocepticisme en disant c'est pas si
grave on n'est pas si sûr pourquoi
prendre des mesures dures
de 92 on a le directeur environ les
directeur environnemental qui dit nous
ne sommes pas si sûr que le climat se
réchauffe si le climat se réchauffait
nous ne sommes pas si sûr que c'est lié
à l'action humaine ce qui est contraire
ce que dit le premier rapport du GIEC en
90 donc il y a clairement une
manipulation du doute des sociologues
américains parlent de fabrique du doute
il y a tout un champ de l'histoire des
sciences qui s'appelle l'histoire de
l'ignorance la gnotologie qui a étudié
ça sauf que jusqu'à présent on savait
que exson avait fait ça que Shell avait
fait ça que BP avait fait ça et dans la
public que j'ai fait il y a deux ans
j'ai montré que elle fait total avait
participé à cela et que ça contribué à
bloquer l'adoption d'une taxe sur le
carbone au niveau européen en 1992 je
répète la question c'est sur des bases
solides de choses institutionnelles qui
arrivent cubique alors j'ai regardé les
archives d'Elf les archives de Total
j'ai regardé les cabinets ministériels
de strauss-kah de La Londe de Matignon
j'ai des sources également au cabinet de
de l'ordre européenne et j'ai étudié
tous ces échanges dans la négociation du
projet de des kotax européenne qui est
sabordée
15 jours avant Rio la conférence de Rio
de juin 92 Conseil des ministres de
l'Industrie qui s'aborde le projet des
kotaxes le commissaire européen Ripa di
Meana est tellement furieux il s'y
attendait tellement pas que démissionne
et que l'Europe se retrouve sans
commissaire européen à Rio elle se
retrouve toute nue l'Europe qui
prétendait être à la pointe de l'action
et de la diplomatie envers
se retrouvent finalement sans son
commissaire européen parce qu'il y a eu
un coup de Trafalgar qui s'est joué dans
les semaines d'avant donc tout ça pour
dire que de la contraction climatique
c'est plus que l'inaction climatique on
a des élites économiques on a des élites
politiques qui ont tout fait pour que
nous ne transitionnions pas or la moitié
des gaz à effet de serre qui ont été
émis aujourd'hui en 2023
la moitié c'est depuis 92 c'est quand 92
on avait émis moitié moins
qu'aujourd'hui quand 92 c'était facile
d'y aller en douceur de bifurquer
lentement prendre des petits engagements
moins 10% moins 20% etc aujourd'hui
quand on nous dit il faut faire moins 40
% d'ici 2030 on est dans le dur mais en
92 c'était possible et donc moi je suis
pas de la génération Greta Thunberg je
suis j'avais 20 ans en 92 je suis né en
mais je comprends la colère de la
génération Greta Thunberg parce que ils
ont compris que dans les années 90 dans
les années 2000 et dans les années 2010
il y a des personnes qui étaient aux
manettes et qui ont tout fait pour que
nous soyons aujourd'hui dans une galère
et un dérèglement climatique qui a des
courses qui va violenter des millions de
personnes le le Haut Commissariat au
réfugiés prévoit qu'on va passer de 30
40 millions de réfugiés climatiques
en ce moment à 250 millions de réfugiés
climatiques en 2050 il y a une
publication récente je suis désolé je
vais pas voir la référence exacte mais
c'est du résilience Center à Stockholm
c'est l'équipe qui a travaillé sur les
planètes ils ont publié un article en
juin pour dire que à chaque fois qu'on
prend 01 degré de réchauffement
supplémentaire à l'échelle planétaire
c'est 140 millions de personnes de plus
qui se retrouvent dans des zones qui ne
sont plus vivables à certaines périodes
de l'année où la chaleur devient
dangereuse donc concrètement
cette inaction cette contraction que
nous avons vécu dans les 10 20 30
dernières années elle représente une
violence énorme pour des centaines de
millions de personnes dès maintenant et
dans le futur c'est des millions perdent
des centaines de millions de personnes
qui vont devoir quitter leur maison
c'est une géopolitique qui va être
complètement bouleversée peut-être que
le 20e siècle a été une grande boucherie
il y a eu deux grandes il y a eu
l'holoco on n'est pas sûr que le 21e
siècle va pas être encore plus barbare
que le 20e à cause de ce dérèglement
planétaire qui a des effets incroyables
sur la géopolitique planétaire et donc
tout ça à un moment il y a des
responsabilités qu'on va chercher et on
aimerait bien que ça ne se reproduise
pas et donc que il y a une jeunesse un
petit peu énervée qui casse quelques
tuyaux et quelques
matériels chez Lafarge qui par ailleurs
à pactisé avec daesh bah ça peut se
comprendre et ça fait partie d'un débat
avoir avec nos dirigeants
Marcel j'ai une question à te poser
quand tu dis on cible
on cible les infrastructures
c'est du langage militaire
acquisition de renseignements action
ça reste des infrastructures mais dans
la tête de l'État il se disent ils ont
dû tomber sur un bouquin de stratégie
militaire c'est conbynique
la page d'après les infrastructures
c'est quoi
c'est à dire
le haut commandement
c'est le général je crois que je partage
pas cette comment dire ce discours
militaire non mais par contre ça peut
être interprété comme un discours
militaire où les actions peuvent être
interprétées comme des actions
militaires j'entends des gens cortiqués
comme un discours de la sociologie
j'entends des gens cortiqués qui ont lu
des bouquins d'auteur de gauche
peut-être qu'il y en a un qui a eu un
bouquin sur la stratégie militaire et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils utilisent
des mots comme cibler des armées
infrastructures
dans la stratégie militaire pour faire
tomber son ennemi
c'est les routes les infrastructures le
haut commandement l'économie les
ressources électriques en eau en
électricité
est-ce que tu peux comprendre que l'État
peut devenir paranoïaque en voyant des
jeunes parler comme des militaires ou
s'approchant d'un discours militaire je
pense pas avec les fondamentaux que
l'État connaît de dégradation climatique
dégradation des rendements dégradations
de la dégradation contre les
dégradations climatiques on pourrait
essayer de penser à la place de l'État
mais on s'aperçoit que l'épreuve du
covid l'a montré on avait un état qui
avait fermé les lithopitos et qui avait
pas de masque et qui prétendait ensuite
être notre Sauveur non je crois qu'il
faut il faut déconstruire qui est dans
l'état qu'elles intéressent ça sert
comment c'est organiser et comment on
pourrait faire mieux
tu viens de sauver Marcel aujourd'hui
donc vous avez des paysans vous avez des
gens qui connaissent bien leur
territoire qui bossent qui connaissent
du coup les entreprises parce qu'ils
croisent les gens qui bossent dans ces
boîtes là et ils savent que il y a tel
bassine qui est construite à côté de
chez eux avec les machines de teles
militaire là on est dans l'observation
du quotidien où vous savez ce qui se
passe sur votre territoire alors c'est
vrai que des vues depuis de Paris on
vient c'est des trucs militaires mais en
fait quand vous êtes dans la campagne
c'est pas du tout des trucs militaires
c'est que vous savez ce que fait votre
voisin vous savez c'est une boîte
d'ailleurs ou si c'est une boîte du coin
qui exécute tel chantier
acquisition d'informations premièrement
ou vous savez juste ce qui se passe en
dehors
toutes les personnes en France qui a
peur qui qui qui s'intéresse un tout
petit peu à ce qui se passe autour de
chez elle ensuite ces personnes là quand
elles se rendent compte qu'on va nous
pondre des projets de bas qui font qui
vont qu'on va nous creuser des des
cratères dans le sol alors que c'est
fait dans dans certaines mesures dans
dans l'illégalité etc les gens
s'organisent et les gens quand ils
s'organisent et qu'ils ont compris qu'en
face on les écoutait pas et bah il se
demande comment avoir de l'impact
comment avoir de l'impact c'est
effectivement aller sur les chantiers
c'est faire des choses qui sont très
concrètes pas une stratégie militaire et
ensuite ce qui est très intéressant par
contre dans les soulèvements de la terre
c'est de dire comment on va faire pour
questionner la politique le plan haut
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'il a annoncé à sa
conscience ou les casserolages je sais
pas si j'en ai déjà parlé mais voilà et
bah on va effectivement s'intéresser à
une des infrastructures atteignable
atteignable
de cette politique globale de l'eau de
cette gestion de l'eau et une des
infrastructures qui paraît les plus
absurde c'est-à-dire sortir l'eau du sol
pour qu'elle s'évapore tranquille dans
des grands trous bâchés
à ce moment là un certain nombre de gens
sur les territoires organisent des
actions dans les actions de la Russie la
Confédération paysanne qui plante une
grande haie pour montrer que c'est quand
il y a des haies que l'eau s'infiltre
dans le sol tranquillement etc vous avez
des balades naturalistes qui vous
apprennent les oiseaux et les insectes
qui qui sont ici vous avez des
pique-niques etc donc on est un peu loin
d'une stratégie militaire par contre
effectivement on est dans une stratégie
un peu plus maligne qu'un certain nombre
d'autres mouvements qui fait un petit
peu peur je pense effectivement
aujourd'hui au gouvernement et juste
parce que au début la question m'était
adressée donc si je peux rajouter un
petit quelque chose sur sur les
infrastructures et sur notamment les
routes donc il y a eu deux actions
pendant la dernière saison la saison 5
de soulèvements de la terre
administrativement dissous actuellement
qui se sont attachés à des routes donc
notamment contre le tronçon Toulouse
Castres et à Rouen et je pense que voilà
donc dans cette logique de stratégie
de où est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'aller se situer et ben quand même les
routes en fait c'est les c'est là où il
y a les flux de marchandises c'est ben
oui non mais tout à fait et c'est en
fait on s'attaquant à des routes on
s'attaque aussi à l'empire de la
logistique et là on peut on rejoint des
luttes notamment comme celle des gilets
jaunes par exemple
et donc à ce moment-là on raccroche les
luttes des gilets jaunes qui ont
notamment bloqué énormément donc
d'infrastructures routière avec les
ronds-points qui ont occupé des
entrepôts
privés l'économie de de flux de son
afflux sanguin
tabasser les infrastructures après c'est
tabassé le corps dirigeant est-ce que
vous pensez que l'État en voyant une
stratégie qui est germé par germination
[Musique]
naturelle ce cheminement qui est peut
être apparenté un cheminement d'ennemis
je neutralise mon ennemi en l'unique en
ces infrastructures ces routes ces
installations énergétiques ces
installations pour la flotte et ainsi de
suite peut être assimilé par l'État qui
n'a jamais lu un bouquin de permaculture
mais qui a eu des bouquins sur les
militaires peut vous dire non mais
attendez les gars
il faudra du renseignement de terrain de
première main ils ont une capacité de
projection d'un claquement de doigts
ils font des stratégies de contournement
pour éviter qu'on les écoute il faut
vite les neutraliser parce que ils se
disent peut-être qu'est-ce qui vont nous
faire après si suivent le manuel du
petit militaire de je neutralise mon
petit ennemi
derrière c'est quoi c'est des attentats
aux personnes c'est des neutralisations
d'état-major c'est quoi
sur la tête sur les terres qu'on pas été
artificialisé point barre des jeunes qui
ont envie de bosser voilà
notamment des amis de d'une association
qui s'appelle l'atelier paysan qui a des
d'ailleurs il y a un article coécrit par
Marcel et une personne de l'atelier
paysan dans le livre qui a le projet de
réinstaller un million d'agriculteurs et
d'agricultrices sur le territoire donc
il y a aussi on aime situation ou
justement les enjeux d'eau vont être de
plus en plus tordus les enjeux
alimentaires vont être de plus en plus
tendus est-ce qu'on veut une société où
l'ensemble de la surface agricole de
notre territoire et accaparé par
quelques milliers de personnes super
équipées avec des super machines et des
drones et des satellites ou est-ce qu'on
veut un territoire dans lequel il y a
des millions de personnes qui sont
capables de produire leur subsistance et
de la distribuer
localement aux urbains qui ne cultivent
pas pas tous et toutes je pense à une
question démocratie si on concentre les
ressources entre les mains de
quelques-uns on aura aussi des problèmes
de partage et de démocratie
les choix qu'on fait sur l'alimentation
et l'eau sont des choix politiques qui
déterminent le de société dans lequel on
va vivre il y aurait une autre chose que
j'ai envie de dire c'est est-ce qu'on
pourrait de temps en temps ne pas penser
à la place de l'État c'est à dire que
peut-être que au soulèvement de la terre
on est porteur d'un changement
civilisationnel dans laquelle peut-être
il y a un autre monde après 500 ans de
capitalistes mais on peut inventer
d'autres choses il a fait la preuve d'un
certain nombre de lacunes qui sont pas
que sont les risques de ce changement de
dérèglement planétaire notamment et
peut-être on peut aussi réfléchir à
sortir de 5000 ans d'histoire de l'État
comme un modèle centralisé je pense à
Homo domesticus de James Scott le modèle
étatique le modèle étatique de voir le
monde ça consiste à avoir un point
central qui est au-dessus des milieux de
vie qui les standardiste qui les
alignent et qui fait en sorte que de ne
voir qu'une tête pour pouvoir les
gouverner de rendre le monde plus simple
plus standardisé pour pouvoir le piloter
comme une société de masse donc on a
réduit les langues on a réduit les
cultures on a standardisé les produits
alimentaires les façons la biodiversité
c'est réduit avec ça ben justement
peut-être qu'il faut sortir de ce modèle
là parce que sinon on va notre droit
dans le mur plein de la des extinctions
de la diversité du dérèglement
planétaire et donc peut-être dans
certains cas sur certains types de
politiques sociales on va avoir besoin
d'un niveau national et de forme
d'organisation à l'échelle de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui l'État mais dans
beaucoup d'autres situations peut-être
il faut ajuster nos fonctionnements
collectifs au milieu qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un bassin hydrographique qu'est-ce
que c'est que une ressource en eau
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un écosystème et
c'est à cette échelle là que les
habitants doivent s'organiser et les
habitantes dans des relations non
instrumentalisées avec les animaux les
végétaux parce que qui va sauver la
planète du dérèglement c'est pas l'état
c'est l'ensemble des agentivités de tous
les êtres humains
c'est pas l'état qui va sauver la
planète c'est vraiment des millions
d'espèces qui travaillent
Pablo serving parlent de l'entraide et
de coopération dans le vivant qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'on respire qui a de
l'oxygène etc c'est pas l'état c'est pas
même j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
services publics mais c'est pas l'état
qui fait ça donc il faut qu'on soit
conscient que l'habitabilité de la
planète nos conditions de vie les formes
de jouets de solidarité qu'on peut avoir
elle dépendent d'une diversité d'être
avec lesquelles on doit coopérer de la
façon la plus horizontale possible et la
plus localisée possible parce que les
milieux sont différents les uns des
autres et l'État est une culture qui a
standardisé tout ça depuis 5000 ans et
qu'il faut dépasser ou au moins
profondément réformé
cet état de basculement
en combien de temps tu le mets en place
sur combien de semaines mois années
décennies siècles et quels sont les
risques de se basculement si c'est un
basculement violent moins violent est-ce
que est-ce que tu as anticipé les
risques de se basculement de ce trou
d'air
le problème c'est que ça fait 250 ans
qu'on nous promet la paix dans le monde
et l'harmonie et l'égalité et d'être
émancipé du travail grâce aux
productivisme industriels du nouveau
capitalisme basé sur les énergies
fossiles c'est le syncimonisme on va
avoir la paix dans le monde grâce à la
production industrielle à l'exploitation
de la terre et on nous promet la paix
universelle avec ça
au 20e siècle avec les grandes
boucheries qu'on a connu et on est en
face du mur du dérèglement planétaire
donc il faut essayer de changer de
logiciel je dis pas que c'est pas facile
que il y a pas des risques de passer par
des moments de chaos et de guerre
claniques encore plus dangereuse que des
formes régulées de course à la puissance
entre États quelque part la bombe
atomique dans les décennies
d'après-guerre ça a été une forme
d'équilibre de la terreur qui a permis
que les régions privilégiées du monde
vivent en paix on peut pas dire la même
chose de l'Indonésie de la Corée de
certaines régions d'Afrique et de
certaines régions d'Amérique centrale
qui elle était en permanence dans des
contextes de guerre mais en tout cas
pour les pays privilégiés effectivement
il y a eu des formes de concurrence
étatique qui ont maintenu une paix pour
certaines sociétés privilégiée et que
effectivement
tout basculement peut on peut perdre des
choses dans ces basculements là est-ce
que tu penses que ça fait peur à l'état
je connais pas l'état en fait l'état il
est incarné par des personnes qui sont
socialisées dans des écoles qui ont des
réseaux sociaux familiaux qui sont
financés dans leur campagne électorale
par des intérêts économiques
particuliers et enfin voilà question
internet ça fait deux heures 17 qu'on
est ensemble on voulait rebondir ce que
sur ce qu'a dit Christophe
question Internet
est-ce que les intervenants ont un des
smartphones si oui avec les nouvelles
lois cela les dérange-t-il d'être
bientôt espionnés
je vous rassure ils sont déjà espionnés
il y a pas besoin de nouvelles lois
bien sûr que toute dans ce type de
mouvement toutes les communications qui
sont fait plutôt en direct dans des
réunions en physique sont beaucoup plus
appréciable que tout ce qui est
communiqué sur smartphone oui moi
personnellement j'ai un smartphone
je fais attention à ce que je dis sur
mon smartphone comme tout le monde je
pense aujourd'hui
autour de ton smartphone même quand tu
es pas au téléphone
parfois parfois
quelle étape psychologique ça génère
chez toi
moi je
je suis pas parano
oui du coup sur la question de l'hygiène
numérique bah effectivement comme il y a
une radicalisation
de la part de l'État sur la surveillance
en tout cas nous dans les comités locaux
il y a beaucoup de questions autour de
ça et on essaie de s'entreformer pour
savoir c'est quoi les bonnes pratiques
évidemment que je vais pas les dire ici
les bonnes pratiques voilà pour notre
propre sécurité quoi mais pratique de
terroristes
qui a une part de bonté dans tout être
humain et que les gens qui nous écoutent
voient une bouleversés par nos arguments
les gens qui écoutent ils sont
bouleversés voilà il y a je suis sûr que
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont
écoutées dans cette salle
mais on va pas non plus devenir
paranoïaque et se bousiller la vie il
faut aussi penser que nos idées sont
sont contagieuses et faire le pari de
l'intelligence humaine quoi parce que
sinon on va se passer justement comme
une avant-garde et on aurait des dérives
terroristes particulièrement au
contraire on pense qu'on peut convaincre
les gens on se prémunit de toute dérive
violente ou quand vous faites des
actions avec tout un tas de gens des des
familles des personnes d'un certain âge
une kermesse et que durant cette
kermesse vous allez jusqu'à une bassine
où vous êtes les faire un muret une
autoroute ou vous allez dé
les surplus de l'agriculture
industrielle devant une la Fédération
des maraîchers nantais où vous allez
récolter les vignes de Bernard Arnault
qui est chez LVMH vendanger chez lui
vous voyez vous faites vous reprenez
quoi les choses vous le faites avec tout
le monde visage
qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est-ce que
vous avez à cacher
[Musique]
des terres en passant outre les les
commissions s'affaires qui sont censées
réguler le prix de la terre agricole en
France oui ça a été accaparé
tu peux parler de la Société
des analyses de la Confédération
paysanne dans le Var qui est beaucoup de
viticulteurs de petits viticulteurs et
il y a des difficultés à s'installer
sur des petites fermes parce que le prix
de la Terre a fortement augmenté dans
cette zone là et que Bernard Arnault
contrôle plusieurs domaines ce qui ont
des marques et des noms différents mais
qui ont le même propriétaire et d'une
façon générale
autant on a eu dans les décennies
d'après guerre une sorte de compromis
social en disant oui on va moderniser
l'agriculture mais dans un cadre
familial l'exploitation a deux UTH les
lois physanie
l'indemnité viagère pour faire partir
les vieux pour que les jeunes
s'agrandissent la SAFER qui préentait
pour éviter que des gros soient trop
gros il y avait une limite maximum à la
grandissement et une possibilité de
préemption par SFR c'est créer en 62 je
pourrais revenir sur comment cette
loi-là a été adoptée c'est suite à des
actions assez musclées d'ailleurs donc
autant on a eu un modèle qui a établi un
certain compromis d'une agriculture
moyenne qui certes produits pour le
marché mais permet l'agriculture
familiale autant on est en train de
sortir de ce complément là aujourd'hui
10% des terres appartiennent à des
sociétés qui sont des sociétés où vous
avez des acteurs chinois des
actionnaires chinois qui viennent
acheter des domaines viticoles ça ne
passe plus par ils s'affaires parce que
c'est juste un changement de part dans
une société actionnariale et ça n'est
plus contrôlé comme ça l'était
auparavant donc on a effectivement une
dérive d'accaparement foncier sur le
territoire français et que les vieilles
régulations dit à 50 ans sont à
réinventer autrement je vous dis ce qui
s'est passé sur la loi de 62 qui fixait
des surfaces maximum on n'avait pas le
droit de s'agrandir si on faisait déjà
plus de temps hectares ça dépend des
départements
et qui donnait un droit de préemption au
safer
cet épisode à ce moment-là il n'arrivait
pas à passer cette mesure cette idée
d'une préemption pour éviter la Casa
parement parce que il y avait des
parlementaires
conservateurs qui disait ouh là là c'est
une attaque à la propriété si on peut
pas vendre à qui on veut rien ne va plus
c'est la révolution
et quelques jours avant la loi il y a
des groupes d'agriculteurs qui vont
envahir le ranch de Jean Gabin l'acteur
qui avait déjà un ranch qui en avait
racheté un deuxième il se pointe à 5h du
matin c'est quasi une prise de tâches
pendant quelques heures il y a une tuile
qui a volé sur le toit gamin porte
plainte donc on a une action un peu
musclée
c'est grâce à cette action là que Pisani
a pu convaincre la majorité du Parlement
d'adopter la mesure
et Jean Gabin a retiré sa plainte dans
les semaines qui ont suivi bah on
pourrait si je vais être le bisounours
beatnik de nous trois je souhaite que
Lafarge retire sa plainte dans les
prochains mois en se disant oui c'est
activistes des soulèvements de la terre
ils avaient bien raison on est en train
de bousiller la planète vous aurez au
moins le même chic que Gabin la
différence entre une tuile et 4 millions
d'euros
je pense que tes bisounours bien vite
quand même
Bouc-Bel-Air je tiens à préciser que
l'action a été relayée par par le
soulèvement mais non pas organisé par
par les soulèvements
très bonne précision Marcel question
internet pour Marcel comment voit-il la
politique européenne sur la mise en
place de la politique écologique quand
voit-elle tu vois bien ça se passe une
catastrophe on a vu Emmanuel Macron qui
a demandé il y a pas longtemps de faire
une pause dans les réglementations
environnementale on a aussi tout un
mouvement vers l'agriculture numérique
qui a notamment été à l'échelle de la
France qui est dans le plan France 2030
donc on nous promet une troisième
révolution de l'agriculture à travers le
numérique la robotique et la génétique
ou en fait on est en train de de
dire que ce qui nous ce qui nous a mené
à la situation actuelle va être la
solution ce qui ne fait aucun sens et
pourtant nous promettant que c'est ce
qui va permettre de résoudre les
problèmes écologiques de l'agriculture
et là là dessus en fait justement donc
si on parle des politiques européennes
là-dessus on peut voir en fait des
similitudes avec ce qui s'est passé
notamment pendant
les notamment sur la question des
impacts environnementaux du numérique où
là là dessus en fait il y a eu du coup
tout un mouvement de contestation de la
croissance économique et à ça au lieu de
remettre en au lieu de remettre en
question la question de la croissance ce
qu'on a fait c'est que on a dit non non
c'est pas la croissance le problème
et on va être capable de découpler la
croissance économique des dégradations
environnementales et donc du coup
l'Union européenne a porté tout un tout
plein de politiques publiques pour la
numérisation de des sociétés en prenant
du coup le développement durable en
disant que voilà le développement
durable allait être la solution au
problème écologique bon maintenant je
pense qu'on a suffisamment de recul pour
voir que que nous en fait il y a pas eu
de découplage il y a les travaux
notamment de Timothée Paris qui
s'intéresse beaucoup à voilà aux
promesses qui a eu sur la question du
découp de la du développement durable de
la croissance verte etc où on sait
pertinemment et je vais te faire là
c'est vraiment des faits scientifiques
quoi que que non c'est pas possible en
fait de décorer les la croissance
économique des dégradations
environnementales et là-dessus en fait
ce qui est assez alertant c'est que le
c'est que le l'Union européenne tient
encore des discours alors peut-être
qu'ils ont changé quelques mots et
parlent maintenant de développement
soutenable mais mais encore à l'échelle
de l'ONU des institutations
internationales il y a encore tout toute
cette croyance de de développement
durable et de découplage ce terme est
encore prôné par les institutions c'est
c'est enfin c'est c'est vraiment ouais
c'est et on peut revenir aussi sur
toutes les sur la construction de la
Fabrique fabrique du doute ou fabrique
de l'ignorance ou là là dessus il y a eu
des rapports les rapports du gretzy et
de la GSMA qui sont des coalitions
d'industrielle du numérique qui en fait
on produit des rapports dans lesquels il
disait que le numérique allait permettre
de
réduire ou d'économiser des gaz à effet
de serre et où en fait donc il y a des
chercheurs notamment Gauthier Roussil
qui sont allés creuser en détail quels
étaient les hypothèses pour avoir ce
type de résultat et qui montre qu'en
fait non en fait ça tenait pas du tout
la route quoi et et ces rapports là ont
beaucoup été utilisés pour prôner des
politiques européennes pour de
développement du numérique notamment
de Xavier donc ce groupe souhaite
revenir à une agriculture juste vivrière
n'est-ce pas arrogant lorsqu'on observe
le besoin mondial en céréales
c'est pas vrai qu'on veut revenir juste
à une agriculture vivrière nous je pense
que ce qu'on observe c'est qu'il y a une
spécialisation de l'agriculture qui est
beaucoup trop forte en France et qui
détruit les territoires donc c'est une
agriculture qui pourra pas qui pourra
pas durer parce que la ressource en eau
ne le permettra pas parce que la
dégradation des sols ne le permettra pas
etc on peut pas continuer à faire que du
cochon en Bretagne à faire que de que
des céréales dans la Beauce à faire que
du que du vin dans le sud de la France
les retours à des fermes en polyculture
élevage par exemple ça nourrit combien
de personnes vous avez des gens qui
reprennent des fermes par exemple j'ai
été en visiter une dans la plaine de
Valence c'était une ferme qui était
majoritairement en maïs dans un la
plaine de Valence voilà il y a que ça
autour les les blagashs du coup ils ont
repris cette ferme et ils l'ont
diversifié ils ont un troupeau de 50
brebis ils ont
un certain nombre de verger il
produisent des œufs il produisent du
tournesol et de la cameline ils font de
l'huile et vous avez une ferme qui
produit tout un tas de choses qui vend
et qui s'en sort mieux économiquement
que les fermes aux alentours d'ailleurs
ce gars qui est assez marrant il a
essayé de prouver aux agriculteurs qui
étaient autour de lui qui en fait ils
gagnaient plus que pour leur montrer que
c'était possible en fait de de changer
de modèle et que et que c'était
intéressant que c'était plus intéressant
dans le travail et qui
je suis désolé je suis pas capable de le
dire par contre j'ai visité cette ferme
elle est économiquement viable et elle
nourrit un certain nombre de gens autour
on n'est pas dans de l'agriculture
vivrière on est dans le mal du futur
de l'agriculture bio à ce moment là mais
derrière si vous voulez si vous voulez
nourrir les gens qui c'est une vraie
question qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas
assez d'argent aujourd'hui par ailleurs
c'est l'inflation donc même les tarifs
qui étaient attractifs jusqu'à
maintenant il y a plein de gens qui ont
du mal à s'alimenter même dans les
grandes surfaces etc avec les prix qui
augmentent et qui sont pas contrôlés par
les agriculteurs et les agricultrices
donc tout le monde a l'accord de coûts
si vous voulez si vous voulez une que
tout le monde puisse manger et que et
que les agriculteurs et agricultrices
travaillent
la terre et puisse le faire durablement
il faut peut-être aller effectivement
vers des systèmes de socialisation de
l'alimentation il y a des gens qui
travaillent là dessus aujourd'hui en
France vous pourrez me compléter et en
plus d'être vous êtes communiste c'est
ça
en tout cas
en tout cas il faut travailler un
système d'aide pour le monde agricole
qui est différent qui est différent de
la PAC actuelle et qui qui ne fait des
aides qu'alecta et qu'au nom d'hectares
et voilà qui favorise que les grandes
fermes et derrière il faut mettre des
politiques en place pour qui
effectivement les gens puissent bouffer
ce qui est produit près de chez eux et
pas seulement ce qui vient de quotidien
on fait comment pour envoyer du des
céréales à ceux qui peuvent pas produire
on fait comment pour envoyer des
céréales à ceux qui sont tapés de la
vermine dans leur champ on fait comment
pour parce que c'est une agriculture
mondiale on fait comment parce que moi
je veux bien
je prends 50 brebis je fais du petit
fromage qui va bien j'appelle des
copains bobos qui vont pouvoir lâcher un
peu supérieur je leur fais du bon
fromage qui va bien 30 à 35% minimum
au-dessus du prix du marché
je vais mieux vivre que tous les
couillons autour qui font du gros ça
c'est sûr je fais comment pour aider des
pays qui ont des problèmes de stock des
problèmes de de vermine est-ce que
l'agriculture vivrière façon
Bambi avec mes brebis qui fait un petit
peu de machin un petit peu de difficulté
ça exporte
de politique d'ajustement structurels
qui ont affaibli les capacités des États
et des pays du Sud à régler à réguler
les marchés à soutenir leur agriculture
l'agriculture est devenue une
marchandise qui doit être dans le
libre-échange qui rentrait dans le cadre
de l'OMC et qui a interdit
aux populations de pouvoir être
souverain dans leur façon de s'alimenter
et dans toute une partie des problèmes
alimentaires des pays du Sud sont pas
liés à une question de production
mondiale et sont liées à cette
désarticulation des politiques publiques
agricoles et alimentaires on pourrait
aussi dire que la moitié des céréales
produites dans le monde va à l'élevage
animal et que donc déjà en mangeant un
peu moins de viande en dégagerait des
excédents je dis pas qu'il faut être
végétarien mais que si on demande aux
gens impact social
dans lequel devrait par exemple on est
un pays qui est effectivement des
capacités agricoles importantes on a un
pays privilégié de ce point de vue là
par rapport à la Tunisie ou
donc effectivement de dire oui ça serait
bien qu'on est des capacités à
exportatrices et qu'on soit pas des
égoïstes qui font juste de la
permaculture pour nous ok
là que nous sommes prêts à partager pour
nourrir le monde mais faisons-le dans un
pacte social dans lequel il y a pas 8
millions de personnes qui sont obligées
d'aller au resto du coeur pour se
nourrir parce qu'on peut dire que le
système actuel c'est une faillite quand
même aussi de ce point de vue là et
définissons la façon dont on veut
produire pour dégager cet excédent et on
veut aussi qu'il y ait des agriculteurs
qui se suicident pas qui soient pas
surendettée voilà
définissons collectivement une politique
agricole après les soulèvements de la
terre dissous
dissous est-ce que ça va changer de nom
ça va changer de ça va faire une petite
pirouette ça va pas reprendre de non ça
va rester dissolu comment ça se passe il
y a des recours qui vont être portés il
y a notamment deux recours un qui va
être assez rapide ou là du coup si
jamais ce si jamais se recourt
fonctionne pendant la procédure à long
terme les soulèvements ne seront plus
dissous et ensuite un recours à plus
long terme qui va aussi contester cette
motion de dissolution et si tous ces
recours là juridiques ne fonctionnent
pas je pense qu'on ira jusqu'au jusqu'à
la justice européenne pour essayer de
faire
de faire sauter la dissolution parce que
c'est quand même contresens historique
quoi quand même et non sinon après je
pense pas que le enfin
on peut pas forcément répondre pour tous
dans le sens où bah il y a 190 comités
locaux actuellement chaque comité locaux
va décider en autonomie est-ce que ils
changent de nom ou pas est-ce qu'il
s'appelle maintenant le comité en
soutien soulèvement de la terre est-ce
qu'il s'appelle les pâquerettes enragés
est-ce qu'il s'appelle les beatniques
est-ce qu'il s'appelle le comité des
soulèvements de la terre enfin et ça ça
va aussi évoluer en fonction des recours
juridiques etc et je pense que
échanger de nom bon je pense pas que
comment dire que ça change grand chose
enfin
voilà est-ce que vous allez continuer à
arracher des cultures
est-ce que vous allez en plus des
cultures qui étaient censées être
sélectionnés pour moins pomper de flotte
et ainsi de suite vous allez continuer
ça ça on peut en plus
il y avait des pesticides quand même ah
oui il y avait des pesticides
est-ce que vous avez un point que vous
souhaitez aborder en particulier
peut-être juste redire un mot quand même
sur les sur les axes thématiques des
soulèvements de la terre qui sont quand
même est-ce que vous êtes d'accord non
non mais du coup il y a notamment l'axe
donc il y a contre lakarement des terres
on en a déjà un peu parlé mais il y a
aussi contre l'artificialisation des
sols et juste je pense que c'est
important de redire de redonner quelques
éléments là-dessus donc en fait ce qui
est là ce qui est en jeu c'est le
l'étalement urbain et le fait de mettre
du béton absolument partout
mais non mais sauf que là on est quand
même un rythme d'étalement urbain qui
est quatre fois plus élevé que juste la
progression de du nombre de personnes
qu'on est donc c'est un rythme qui est
démesuré ensuite on sait que le que la
terre en fait elle me rend plein de
services que ce soit nous nourrir elle
absorbe elle absorbe l'eau elle empêche
qu'il y a des qu'il y a des de l'eau
partout etc elle absorbe le carbone etc
et du coup mettre plein de de béton
dessus c'est vraiment une hérésie et ça
là dessus donc il y a tous les projets
autoroutiers dont on a un petit peu
parlé mais du coup le ouais le
l'artificialisation des sols je pense
que c'est important d'avoir conscience
de à quel point c'est vraiment
problématique on peut parler du béton
notamment où le béton c'est ça
représente 8% du CO2 qui est émis à
l'échelle globale
39% pour tout le domaine du BTP 33 en
France et alors là ces chiffres là
ces chiffres là c'était dans dans le
livre là exactement et sinon il y a
aussi un article de basta qui remet tous
les chiffres sur ben voilà là en France
tous les ans c'est 50
000 hectares de terre qui sont qui sont
artificialisés tous les ans ça
représente je crois 350 de ce qu'ils
disent dans cet article du coup ça
représente 300 l'équivalent de 350
terrains de foot qui sont artificialisés
tous les jours en France enfin c'est et
et juste aussi pour dire quelques mots
de nouveau sur des choses qui me semble
vraiment très pertinentes sur la
critique notamment des infrastructures
routières c'est que il y a toute cette
idée que si on met des routes ça va
permettre de désengorger et il va y
avoir moins de trafic sauf que il y a
des travaux scientifiques qui prouvent
que
alors là sur les sources c'est enfin là
c'est vraiment en fait tout le comment
dire tout le domaine il y a notamment un
il y a eu une revue de la littérature
dans les années 98 avec trois chercheurs
qui ont publié ça mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment un consensus dans ce dans le
dans le domaine dans le domaine
scientifique qui s'intéresse à ça que
plus il y a de routes plus il y a de
trafic et moins moins il y a de route
moins il y a de trafic et il y a
vraiment des il y a eu des études qui
ont répertorié de nombreux cas et qui
l'ont étudié de manière très sérieuse
la transition énergétique les panneaux
solaires les éoliennes la transition le
plan de transition énergétique allemand
qui consiste à construire x terrain de
foot de panneaux solaires x centrale
éolienne of Shorin shore
tous les jours jusqu'en 2030 c'est bien
c'est pas bien
une idée non
d'une façon générale on peut pas penser
que la transition énergétique c'est que
de remplacer une technique par une autre
ou une source d'énergie par une autre
c'est un vrai changement civilisationnel
une autre façon de vivre une autre façon
de répartir les ressources
premièrement et deuxièmement du coup
on nous fait la promesse des énergies
renouvelables mais dans un une
consommation énergétique qui continue à
croître puisque l'économie numérique va
faire exploser les besoins énergétiques
et dans ce cadre là d'une expansion de
la consommation énergétique la
transition par les énergies
renouvelables c'est du bidon ça va c'est
la même chose que de d'être passé du
bois au charbon au début du 19e siècle
on repousse les problèmes vers
l'extraction ailleurs de cobalt de
nickel de terre rare etc qui génère des
dégâts sanitaires dans les travailleuses
et travailleurs qui travaillent
là-dedans dans les rivières les milieux
etc qui sont incroyables
et c'est localisé en des milliers
d'endroits de mines mais ça devient un
problème global et donc c'est une fuite
en avant
donc oui des panneaux solaires et des
éoliennes pourquoi pas si elles sont low
tech elles sont discutées
démocratiquement et qu'elle s'enfon dans
un cadre de descente énergétique globale
non mais rappelez que le GIEC par
exemple pointe que l'étalement
urbain c'est l'une des premières causes
du réchauffement climatique et de la
chute de la biodiversité
est-ce que tu veux aborder un point
qu'on a pas abordé
le dernier point par exemple sur la
dissolution moi j'ai l'impression que
finalement c'est une réponse extrêmement
faible à un mouvement qui a grandi comme
celui-là un mouvement qui finalement va
faire des campagnes très localisés sur
des territoires précis sur des projets
précis on dit un je peux pas avoir le
problème je dissous c'est un peu comme
mettre des enfants en prison quand ils
sortent dans les rues parce qu'ils sont
pas contents parce que parce qu'un
policier a tué l'un des leurs
donc c'est une réponse extrêmement
faible c'est un peu comme vous
connaissez peut-être pas vous voyez
cette plante la renouée du Japon là elle
pousse dans les milieux très pollués et
puis elle est invasive vous les voyez
sur vous la voyez sur les bords
d'autoroutes avec des grandes feuilles
vertes comme ça et quand vous essayez de
la des radiquer la débroussailleuse
c'est tout ce que vous voulez les des
produits tout ça et en fait elle se
répand de plus en plus quoi les
soulèvements de la terre aujourd'hui il
y a eu des rencontres qui ont été
déterminantes il y a eu des gestes qui
ont fait mouche il y a eu des gens qui
se sont qui se sont
identifiés les uns des autres les uns
les autres il y a eu des comités qui ont
été créés de partout etc je vois pas
comment du jour au lendemain ça peut
faire
on peut ne plus exister c'est ça donc ça
va je pense quoi qu'il arrive en plus
c'est des c'est des héritages d'actions
c'est des choses qui nous précèdent tous
les types d'actions qui sont faits
toutes les associations qui se sont
liées entre elles et qui ont su trouver
une sorte d'alchimie ensemble et qui ont
su
des bons moments je pense comme ça TOI
et ben je pense que actuellement en tout
cas on ne peut pas faire taire un tel
mouvement et ça se voit depuis les
menaces de dissolution Gérald Darmanin
il a beau répéter répéter et qu'aux
terrorisme tout ça ça ne prend pas ça
fait que le mouvement se propage et on
voit des des signes vous voyez le signe
des soulèvements de la terre signifie la
prise de terre bah oui c'est les
électriciens qui reconnaissent c'est pas
les les hippies
et bah ce signe ce signe on voit partout
et les personnes
qui étaient qui ont été au tout départ
du mouvement qui avait des actions à 400
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elles sont
complètement dépassées par ce qui se
passe et toutes les personnes dont moi
je fais partie qui les ont rejoint au
fur et à mesure et bah on se dit qu'il y
a une forme de comme ça de dépassement
d'un d'un mouvement volontariste au
départ qui qui a pris par je ne sais
quel
[Musique]
magie quoi c'est pas de la magie je
pense que les gens sont tout à fait
conscients que ça part en sucette et que
vous agrégez des choses de par votre
bienveillance entre vous votre
communication horizontale votre respect
entre les autres que ça semble se
propager certes et que vous faites très
peur parce que vous opposez et vous
proposez une autre perception et c'est
ça qui fait peur bon on va pas s'avancer
plus que ça
est-ce que vous avez chacun
deux livres à conseiller pas trois parce
que on est trois fois trois neuf on va
mettre trop de temps ça fait déjà deux
heures 43 que nous sommes ensemble
deux livres Christophe
voilà je suis historien donc je vais
prendre des histoires le premier c'est
Mike Davis génocide tropicaux
ça raconte une catastrophe climatique
passer des événements aligno qui
provoque 50 millions de morts dans les
régions tropicales Chine Inde Afrique
Amazonie et que cet auteur monte c'est
pas juste une catastrophe naturelle
c'est le nombre de morts et renforcer
par le fait qu'on vit dans un système
colonial à cette époque là et que en
pleine famille l'Inde continue à
exporter des produits alimentaires vers
la métropole britannique donc il fait
toute une analyse sur comment
s'entrecroisent les dominations sociales
coloniales raciales et les catastrophes
climatiques vers lesquelles on est en
train d'aller également quoi il y a des
événements El Nino qui sont annoncés
pour cette année l'année prochaine et le
deuxième c'est Grégoire chamailloux qui
s'appelle la société un gouvernable qui
est une analyse des stratégies des
élites économiques capitalistes pour
répondre aux critiques sociales et aux
critiques environnementales on apprend
par exemple que Nestlé à la fin des
années 70 il y a un boycott sur le lait
en poudre qui tue des enfants en Afrique
toutes les assos chrétiennes qui suivent
le boycott que fait Nestlé pour lutter
contre ça ils embauchent un spécialiste
de la contre-insurrection de former à la
CIA en Amérique centrale et qui va
élaborer une stratégie contre les
mouvements tiers-mondistes et les
mouvements écolos et donc ce livre nous
permet de ne pas sous-estimer le fait
qu'en face de nous il y a des gens qui
veulent pas le bien humain le bien de la
planète et qui ont des stratégies donc
vous étiez pas lu de grands stratège
militaires mais lisez Grégoire
chamaillod
moi je te conseille tu lances pas mal
vous êtes fait un filtrer ou pas
physiquement parlant
vous savez pas
les mouvements écolos en Angleterre se
sont fait écolo et radicaux sont fait
fortement infiltrés dans les années 90
2000 il peut y avoir des doutes sur des
infiltrations à la date de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes dans les années
2010 les soulèvements de la terre on
imagine que à chaque fois qu'il y a des
réunions il y a des oreilles de l'État
qui sont présentes mais Marcel de
bouquins je pense que vu la situation
actuelle avec les révoltes populaires à
l'heure où des personnes
pensent que mettre des mineurs en prison
ça peut être une bonne idée je pense que
c'est vraiment nécessaire de relire
surveiller punir de Foucault qui
explique vraiment le comment dire la
fabrique de cette imaginaire autour du
délinquant de comment est-ce que de le
dispositif de la prison comment est-ce
qu'on fait ça pousse plutôt les gens à
et que ça enfonce en fait les gens dans
des dynamiques de récidives etc et
je suis désolé je vais squeezer
voilà et le deuxième du coup serait
reprendre la terre aux machines de
l'atelier paysan qui est aux éditions du
Seuil anthropocène et qui retrace toute
l'histoire justement de la malnommée
modernisation agricole et je pense que
c'est vraiment des bases nécessaires à
avoir pour comprendre ce qui se passe
actuellement
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
ensuite Christophe un conseil pour les
jeunes générations et ensuite Marcel un
conseiller pour les jeunes générations
moi j'ai pas le temps de lire déjà bon
je suis trop occupé du coup il y a des
livres audio il y a des livres du coup
je conseille un livre La guerre des
pauvres Éric Vuillard petit livre très
rapide à lire sur une séquence
historique intéressante
ensuite
un livre et je dis une citation quand
même de Thomas Sankara qu'on m'a qu'on
m'a imposé de dire ce soir
un ami il nous faut choisir entre le
champagne pour quelques-uns et l'eau
pour tous voilà pourquoi les
soulèvements de la terre ça va pas se
faire dissoudre comme ça parce qu'il y a
quelque chose de primordial là-dedans
voilà c'est ça que je dis aux jeunes aux
jeunes générations il faut se donner les
moyens
si on veut pouvoir choisir entre ça et
ça parce qu'en face on va pas nous les
laisser donc il faut avoir prise sur les
choses il faut habiter d'enterrer dans
des territoires faire des enquêtes de
terrain essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe autour de nous agir en conséquence
Christophe un conseil pour les jeunes
générations alors pour les jeunes
générations et pour mes collègues
scientifiques du monde universitaire je
pense qu'il faut qu'on sorte du modèle
selon lequel avant on savait pas qu'on
dégradait la planète la science
maintenant nous dit que ça y est on est
en train de faire quelque chose et que
naturellement maintenant qu'on cesse ça
va bien se passer on est déjà sur la
bonne voie etc on fait face à des
décennies de contractions
anti-écologique de la part d'une série
d'acteurs il faut les comprendre il faut
les interpréter et du coup il faut
réfléchir à qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à
ça
justement c'est sortir du côté
bisounours
Marcel un conseil pour les jeunes
générations je conseillerais de
personnes qui qui le peuvent
matériellement
et qui le souhaitent de s'engager
d'aller militer d'aller trouver alors
pas forcément dans un comité local mais
pourquoi pas mais ça peut être vraiment
en fonction de l'endroit où on est quoi
de s'engager parce que vraiment le
je vois nombre de personnes qui sont qui
sont vraiment pris dans cette écho
anxiété et le fait justement de d'agir
de rencontrer des gens de militer avec
des gens de faire des choses concrètes
etc je vois la joie que ça procure à
toutes ces personnes et du coup vraiment
quand c'est possible pour les personnes
quand ils le peuvent j'aurais qu'un
conseil c'est de s'engager
mesdames et messieurs merci
[Musique]